die
ja-stimmen morgen meine damen und herren
also heute wird hier abgestimmt vier
vorschläge liegen auf dem tisch der
bundeskanzler werden gehört wollte ja
eine impfpflicht auf jeden fall kann
sich aber nicht durchsetzen in seiner
eigenen koalition das liegt vor allen
dingen an der fdp deswegen hat er das
ganze in die fraktionen beordert
gruppenübergreifend hat man gearbeitet
und nun liegen also vier vorschläge auf
dem tisch die opposition hält sich nicht
so richtig an diese vorgabe denn die afd
liegt einen eigenen antrag vor komplett
geschlossen und darin fordert sie das
ende aller maßnahmen auch die
impfpflicht für gruppen die schon seit
dem 15 märz gelten in krankenhäusern und
pflegeheimen die werden sollen
aufgehoben werden es gibt einen
vorschlag der cdu csu auch die besteht
auf einen eigenen eigenen fraktions
vorschlag da geht es um ein impf
register und stufen pläne die dann im
herbst scharf geschaltet werden können
und bei der fdp da hatte man sich ein
bisschen aufgefächert wolfgang kubicki
und ungefähr 50 mitstreiter da sind
leute dabei viele aus von den linken
aber auch zwei cdu abgeordnete viele
fdp-abgeordnete also die fordern keine
impfpflicht aber vermehrt es werden für
eine impfpflicht sie sind anders als die
afg der meinung dass das sehr gut ist
sich persönlich impfen zu lassen das
aber der staat das nicht befehlen sollte
und befehlen kann und dann gab es eine
gruppe um den fdp gesundheitsminister
ullmann die haben gesagt wir müssen die
menschen erstmal ordentlich beraten und
wenn das alles nichts nützt müssen wir
dann im herbst eine impfung vornehmen ab
50 jahren diese gruppe hat sich jetzt
der stärksten gruppe angeschlossen diese
gruppe von hermann hatte ungefähr 45
mitglieder und die stärkste gruppe 237
mitglieder das ist die gruppe die von
vielen ampel politikern forciert wurde
eine impfpflicht für alle ab 18 jahren
diese gruppe ist jetzt den anderen
entgegengekommen hat gesagt auch wir
sind für ein impf register einloggen von
der cdu/csu ist das natürlich und sie
hat gesagt wir vereinigen uns jetzt mit
der gruppe von hermann und werden eine
impfpflicht ab 60 einführen vorher
müssen alle beraten werden und es gibt
eine möglichkeit im juni da noch
auszusteigen wenn es gut voran geht und
im herbst beraten wir dann nochmal ob
die 18 jährigen und älter sich auch
genügend geimpft haben oder ob man da
nicht doch eine impfpflicht für alle
einführen kann also eine komplizierte
ausgangslage
es geht nicht nur um sachfragen sondern
auch um taktische fragen und ich will
darüber diskutieren mit meinen beiden
gästen dirk wiese und sepp müller beide
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
ihre parteien spd und cdu/csu spielt
aber keine rolle heute denn ich habe ja
gesagt fraktionsübergreifend herr wiese
sie also stehen für diesen antrag
impfen für alle sie haben das jetzt
modifiziert impfen ab 60 unter anderem
ja auch ein im register muss eingeführt
werden es soll eine beratung stattfinden
wer soll das machen wir haben uns erst
mal als stärkste gruppe in der
verantwortung gesehen am wochenende auf
die anderen zuzugehen um ihr heute im
deutschen bundestag eine entscheidung
herbeizuführen die die bürgerinnen und
bürger auch zu recht erwarten nach sehr
langen diskussionen in den vergangenen
wochen und ich will das noch mal
herausstellen wir wollen eine
impfpflicht letztendlich auf 60 weil wir
wollen für den herbst vorsorge treffen
wir wollen dass diese pandemie
beherrschbar wird wir wollen nicht
wieder über freiheitseinschränkende
maßnahmen im kommenden herbst bei einer
möglichen neuen welle diskutieren
sondern wir wollen vor die bälle vom wir
wollen vorsorge treffen das eint uns
letztendlich darum haben wir diesen
kompromiss den ich für richtig halte auf
den weg gebracht auch mit einem schritt
auf die union zu im hinblick auf das im
register und wir werben heute hier
letztendlich für die mehrheit ich halte
das auch für richtig zu einer
entscheidung zu kommen herr müller die
union liegt ihr einen eigenen antrag vor
dass im vorsorge gesetzt was ist daran
besser als an dem vorschlag den herrn
wiese vertritt ja uns eint das ziel das
der vorsorge betreiben vom herbst und
deswegen ist es richtig dass die
ampelkoalition er jetzt unser gutes
thema das im register übernommen haben
aber sie machen zwei unterschiede wir
wollen weiterhin auf freiwillige
beratung setzen hier möchte die ampel
eine beratungspflicht und die ampel wird
jetzt eine impfpflicht für ab 60 jährige
allen führen das halten wir nicht für
verhältnismäßig weil wir gar nicht
wissen welche variante im herbst auf uns
zukommt und deswegen möchten wir einen
regelmäßigen bericht des
bundesgesundheits mit ist das im
deutschen bundestag und nicht über
markus lanz beraten sehen dann wird wir
darüber entscheiden können ob es
notwendig ist eine impfpflicht
stufenweise einzuführen ab herbst sie
fordern eine beratungspflicht was
eigentlich auch logisch ist wenn man
sieht dass der kanzler gesagt hat bis
februar sind 80 prozent geimpft hat
nicht geklappt wir sind bei einer quote
von 76 prozent
warum ist das in deutschland so schwer
und b wiederhole ich meine frage von
vorhin wer soll denn beraten ich glaube
die beratungspflicht ist wichtig sie
vorzuschalten um nochmal aufzuklären die
bürgerinnen und bürger die noch nicht
geimpft sind auch über vielleicht
falschinformationen noch aufzuklären was
über die ärzteschaft die apotheken
letztendlich angegliedert sein soll was
jetzt beginnen soll wenn das zum erfolg
wird sagen wir ja auch ganz klar muss
man überlegen ob man das dann überhaupt
scharf schalten soll das halte ich auch
für absolut richtig aber hier ist noch
sehr viel luft nach oben ich gebe ihnen
das beispiel des bundeslandes bremen wo
wir fast eine impfquote von über 90
prozent der bevölkerung haben wo viele
sehr gute beratungsleistungen erbracht
worden ist in bayern und sachsen ist das
anders gelaufen dort haben wir
schwierige impfquoten in der derzeitigen
situation die uns große sorgen für den
herbst bereiten also von daher nochmal
wir haben hier einen sehr guten
vorschlag aus meiner sicht vorgelegt es
ist ein kompromiss der unterschiedliche
gruppen vereint der aber auch die klare
unterstützung der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz hat denn
ich will noch mal daran erinnern dass
sich alle ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidenten der bundesländer
auch für eine allgemeine impfpflicht
ausgesprochen haben auch die der cdu csu
die das noch mal bekräftigt haben vor
ein paar wochen und von daher sehen wir
auch dass die unionsfraktion sich hier
auch gegen ihre eigenen
ministerpräsidenten heute stellt herr
müller ein schwieriges problem bei ihrem
antrag finde ich dass sie im herbst
reagieren wollen die auf die situation
angemessen das ist insofern verständlich
als dass der impfstoff den wir jetzt
haben ja so richtig gegen nikon gar
nicht funktioniert und sie wollen gucken
welche virus dann da wütet aber ist das
nicht ein problem wenn sie dann erst
anfangen ältere menschen zum beispiel zu
impfen das dauert ja eh die dann
sozusagen ein schutz haben ist das nicht
zu spät was sie vorschlagen danke für
die frage das lässt auch die möglichkeit
zu klarzustellen dass mit der
erstimpfung die überlastung des
gesundheitssystems entgegengewirkt wird
das sagen nicht nur wir sondern
wissenschaftler mit studien und karl
lauterbach hat da von anfang januar
zitiert die erstimpfung hilft 14 tage
später gegen 1 tödlichen verlauf mit dem
corona virus und sie sprechen jetzt
richtiger weise an die impfungen gegen
das corona virus jetzt mit dem jetzigen
impfstoff ist noch nicht sicher war ob
die gegen die impfung gegen das virus
wird welches dann im herbst bietet ja
das ist ja die enttäuschung von vielen
die geburt sind und reihenweise krank
werden dass das nicht so funktioniert
wie man sich das als laie vorstellt ich
lasse mich impfen dann bin ich safe
vielleicht bin ich dann nicht ganz so
krank dass rk ii hat jetzt eine
untersuchung dass über 60-jährige 0,2
prozent der gebuchten einander auf der
intensivstation der nicht geimpft das
sind ein prozent zu riesig groß ist der
unterschied zumindest bei nikon im
moment nicht und muss noch mal deutlich
klarstellen und das ist auch etwas was
ich gerade in vielen zuschriften als
frage bekomme die impfung ist nicht hin
sozusagen schützt nicht vor einer
sterilen immunität sie können sich noch
infizieren aber die impfung schützt
nachweislich davor dass sie einen
schweren verlauf einer infektion haben
und das muss man immer noch mal
hervorheben die impfung schützt vor
allem schweren verlauf nachweislich das
können wir auch ganz klar belegen an den
studien die wir haben und das ist ja
letztendlich auch das ziel was wir haben
die schweren verläufe kommen in die
krankenhäusern sie belasten das
gesundheitssystem und darum ist ja die
vorsorge vor dem herbst gerade bei der
gruppe der über 60-jährigen so wichtig
weil dort nachweislich die meisten
schweren verläufe sind und es ist nicht
so dass eine impfung bereits ausreichend
ist sie brauchen mindestens zwei
impfungen für eine grundimmunisierung
besser noch den schutz durch die
musterung und darum ist der vorschlag
den mechanismus den die union vorschlägt
viel zu spät und vor die welle zu kommen
das was die union vorschlägt wird wieder
dazu führen dass wir freiheits
einschränkungen im herbst haben dass wir
geschäftsschließungen haben auswirkungen
auf die schulen haben und das ist aus
meiner sicht keine vorsorge herr müller
haben sie verständnis für bürger die
sagen der staat kann mir das nicht
anweisen ich will nicht geimpft werden
weil der gesetzgeber das ist der gleiche
gesetzgeber der in dieser woche eine
riesen kapriole geschlagen hat sie haben
gerade die ministerpräsidenten
angesprochen die gesundheitsminister
haben gemeinschaftlich beschlossen mit
dem bundesgesundheitsminister dass alle
maßnahmen abzuschaffen sind und dass
eben ein erkrankter auch nicht mehr in
quarantäne gehen muss wir haben das alle
mitgekriegt der
bundesgesundheitsminister hat das dann
anderthalb tage später oder nachts
zurückgeholt dieser gleiche gesetzgeber
der sagt also das sind zu viele
einschränkungen
das nehme jetzt mal alles schön zurück
gegen jeden menschenverstand dieser
gesetzgeber sagt dann aber im herbst auf
jeden fall ihr müsst geimpft werden
damit ihr auch geschützt sei das ist
doch schon zufrieden das durcheinander
was sie ansprechen hat karl lauterbach
und der bundeskanzler zu verantworten
die menschen draußen verstehen diese
pandemie politik zu recht nicht mehr und
wenn sie jetzt den gesetzesentwurf sich
anschauen dann sieht der gesetzesentwurf
eine immunisierung ab drei spritzen vor
das wäre der nachweis gleichzeitig wirbt
karl lauterbach für über 60 jährige mit
vier spritzen die stiko empfiehlt für
über 70-jährige die vierte spritze also
da passten wissenschaft und
kommunikation in die breite
öffentlichkeit nicht zusammen und
deswegen wird das ziel auch nicht
erreicht was die amtlicher erzielen
möchte eine höhere impfbereitschaft zu
erreichen weil die menschen einfach
durcheinander sind wo ich die ampel
politik in der pandemie wie sie ist es
nicht auch verfassungsrechtlich ein
problem also in griechenland gibt es
diese impfpflicht über 60 in italien
eine impfpflicht über 50 und die
österreicher als graf hatte gebracht
eine impfpflicht zu verabschieden und
mussten die gleich wieder aussetzen weil
sie nämlich gesagt haben dass omikron
virus ist mit so einem harmlosen verlauf
für die meisten menschen verbunden dass
dieser grundrechtseingriff einfach nicht
akzeptabel ist warum wollen wir uns so
was auslasten wir halten das was wir
vorgelegt haben für verfassungsrechtlich
zulässig es war folgt ein legitimes ziel
mit dem schutz vor einer überlastung des
gesundheitssystems und darum auch den
schutz von uns fielen die geplante
operationen verschieben müssen die nicht
stattfinden können und darum ist es ein
verfassungs legitimes ziel das wir damit
verfolgen das ist geeignet erforderlich
es auch verhältnismäßig das hatten die
anhörung die wir im deutschen bundestag
gehabt haben und man eindeutig bestätigt
und ist es ja auch so dass das
bundesverfassungsgericht auch die
einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht in
einer entscheidung noch einmal bestätigt
hat die wir auf den weg gebracht haben
also von daher verfassungsrechtlich ist
das was wir auf den weg bringen zu
lassen jetzt kommt noch ein bisschen zum
politischen raufen herr müller ist das
was die union der macht mit einem
eigenen brief an die abgeordneten der
empfiehlt also wenn ihr antrag nicht
angenommen wird dann bitte keinen
anderen antrag zustimmen nicht eindeutig
darauf gerichtet den kanzler einen
auszuwischen eben ganz klar zu zeigen
ohne die union in deiner ampel hast du
keine mehrheit für gesetze und so ziel
dass es unseren guten antrag
durchzubringen dafür werden wir auch
heute werden dafür liefen auch in den
letzten tagen die telefone heiß wir
haben versucht mit der gruppe um andrew
ullmann und dirk wiese auch ein
kompromiss zu finden der vorgelegt ist
kein kompromiss mit unserer gruppe und
dann ist es folgerichtig dass natürlich
die fraktion mit ihren abgeordneten noch
mal für unseren antrag wird bei dieser
ist zielgerichtet dieser wird uns vor
der herbst wälder schützen wenn wir den
umsätzen sind wir gut gewappnet für die
dinge die im herbst auf uns zukommen
sollten muss ich noch mal sagt
nachsitzen im prinzip ist ja auch die
union oder die meisten in der union sind
für eine impfpflicht im herbst nur in
der lage angepasst wenn jetzt ihr antrag
nicht angenommen wird dann wäre es doch
folgerichtig dass viele sagen gar nix
kommt stimmig dem antrag der
mehrheitsgruppe zu ja ich gar nichts
kommt das sehen wir bei der sektoralen
impfpflicht wie teilweise schlecht der
die regierung diese umgesetzt hat und
deswegen ist unser werben auch für unser
gesetz wir hätten uns gerne noch ein
wenig zeit genommen um es auch gemeinsam
mit der ampel auf dem weg zu bringen
damit wir die feinheiten wer also alles
umsetzen auch ausgestalten können sie
hören ja die kritik der gesetzlichen
krankenversicherung sie hören die kritik
der kommunen an dem gesetzesentwurf und
jörg wiese karl lauterbach und olaf
scholz dieses nicht umsetzbar erwiesen
ich hab so ein bisschen das gefühl bei
ihnen ging es die letzten vier tage
darum egal was hauptsache impfpflicht
sie haben zwei mal modifiziert sie haben
auch einen free geste eingebaut um der
union entgegen zu kommen und christian
doerr immer in der fraktionschef der fdp
dem ullmann antrag nahestand hat gesagt
ich kann bei dem anderen nicht mitmachen
und er hat das auch angedeutet ich
übersetze dass mal was sie davor liegen
ist ja letzten endes doch immer noch der
versuch eine impfpflicht für alle im
herbst durchzusetzen denn das ist ja
dieser zwei stufen plan erst ab 60 und
wenn das die beratung nicht funktioniert
dann eben für alle nein mit diesem
kompromiss übernehmen wir verantwortung
weil wir glauben es ist wichtig vor die
welle im herbst zu kommen damit wir
nicht noch mal und das sage ich sehr
deutlich nicht wieder
freiheitseinschränkung im herbst haben
das möchte niemand und darum ist es
wichtig vor die bälle zu kommen
frühzeitig vorzusorgen und das machen
wir mit unseren kompromissvorschlag den
ich für richtig halte aber ich muss
schon sagen auch wir waren gestern im
laufe des tages erstaunt dass friedrich
merz sozusagen den abgeordneten der
cdu/csu in einer ethischen medizinischen
debatte sozusagen fesseln angelegt hat
dass er ihnen klar vorgibt wie sie
abzustimmen haben das ist schon ein sehr
merkwürdiges demokratieverständnis des
fraktionsvorsitzenden der cdu und zwei
halten sich zumindest zwei halten sich
nicht dran die sind bei wolfgang
kubickis antrag aber davon mal abgesehen
hand aufs herz die
unions-ministerpräsidenten werben für
eine werbung die fraktion tut das quasi
zumindest für den mehr als antrag hier
nicht passt das zusammen ja unsere
ministerpräsidenten sind natürlich im
steten austausch ich habe gestern noch
mal mit einigen telefoniert und sie
finden unseren antrag richtig weil er
uns gut vorbereitet und vor allem auch
gemeinsam mit der ampel müssten wir uns
auf den weg machen die impfzentren
weiter zu finanzieren weil wo wollen sie
hier angedachte beratungspflicht denn
umsetzen die ampel möchte die
impfzentren ab mitte dieses jahres nicht
mehr kofinanzieren das ist schizophren
das ist das falsche signal
und da muss die ampel jetzt arbeiten das
wollten wir mit einbringen für gespräche
war dann keiner mehr bereit herr müller
herr wiese vielen dank für das interview
dann gehen wir haben eine dame nicht
gäbe jetzt rein denn da wird es gleich
losgehen und es wird heute ein wahrer
abstimmungsmarathon denn man ist sich
noch nicht mal als darüber einig unter
den fraktionen in welcher reihenfolge
die drei anträge und der eine
gesetzentwurf hier abgestimmt werden
soll denn das was die mehrheitsgruppe
vorliegt das ist der einzige
ausgearbeitete gesetzentwurf das spielt
aber keine große rolle auch dieser
gesetzentwurf mit 237 noch vorgestern
jetzt haben sich noch einige
angeschlossen hat momentan keine
mehrheit wie kommt dass es reicht die
einfache mehrheit im deutschen bundestag
heute für die ab verabschiedung einer
dieser vorschläge aber
wenn mehr personen mit nein stimmen als
mit ja dann ist eben der jeweilige
vorschlag nicht angenommen und am
schluss kann es gut sein dass alle vier
vorschläge hierdurch fallen das wird
eine längere zeremonie werden die
bundestags präsidentin bärbel bas wird
uns sicherlich gewohnt souverän hier
durch den heutigen vormittag geleiten
zunächst können wir uns erst einmal
freuen auf den austausch der argumente
denn es wird eine 70 minütige debatte
folgen und danach dann der
abstimmungsmarathon und bleiben sie bei
uns wir werden ihnen das ganze hier
übersetzen und näher bringen wie sie das
von uns gewohnt sind heute übrigens
werden wir 25 jahre und ich hoffe die
nächsten 25 jahre meine damen und herren
halten sie uns auch noch die treue
da kommt wir machen mal einen schnellen
schriftführer wechsel
mit folgendem hintergrund weil dann kann
ich meiner kollegin christa an yüksel
nachträglich zu ihrem sechzigsten
geburtstag gratulieren
[Musik]
außerdem müssen wir noch die mitglieder
des stiftungsrates der stiftung
humanitäre hilfe für durch blutprodukte
hiv infizierte personen für die
verbleibende amtszeit wählen auf
vorschlag der fraktion der spd soll die
kollegin dagmar schmidt gewählt werden
sie folgt mir als mitglied in dieses
gremium
die fraktion der cdu csu schlägt den
kollegen tino sorge als nachfolger für
die ausgeschiedene kollegin karin maag
vor ich gehe davon aus dass da ein
verständnis herrscht ich sehe auch kein
widerspruch dann ist das so damit sind
dann die kollegin dagmar schmidt und der
kollege tino sorge gewählt wir kommen
zur tagesordnung als zusatzpunkt 6 soll
der antrag der fraktion der afg auf
drucksache 20 schrägstrich
1346 aufgesetzt und in verbindung mit
tagesordnungspunkt 7 beraten werden der
tagesordnungspunkt 20 wird abgesetzt an
dieser stelle soll nunmehr ein antrag
der fraktion der cdu/csu
aufgerufen werden der bislang als
zusatzpunkt 3 buchstabe a bei den ohne
debatten punkten auf gesetzt waren
zusatzpunkt 3 buchstabe c wird in
verbindung mit tagesordnungspunkt 25
aufgerufen ich mache schließlich darauf
aufmerksam dass der gesetzentwurf auf
drucksache 20 schrägstrich 737
nachträglich dem ausschuss für inneres
und heimat sowie dem ausschuss für
digitales überwiesen werden soll auch
hier sehe ich keinen widerspruch dann
ist das so beschlossen
ich rufe jetzt auf den
tagesordnungspunkt 6 beratung mehrerer
vorlagen zur einführung bzw zur nicht
einführung einer impfpflicht ich möchte
sie schon jetzt über das weitere
verfahren informieren nach der aus
werden wir zunächst die reihenfolge der
abstimmung festlegen da hierüber kein
einvernehmen erzielt werden konnte
hierzu ist dann auch das wort zur
geschäftsordnung gewünscht nach der
festlegung der reihenfolge beginnen dann
die namentlichen abstimmung über die
einzelnen vorlagen das gesamte
abstimmungsverfahren kann
voraussichtlich bis zu zweieinhalb
stunden dauern
für die aussprache selbst wurde eine
dauer von 68 minuten beschlossen
ich weise auf die vereinbarung hin dass
die reden der kolleginnen und kollegen
deren rede wunsch nicht berücksichtigt
werden kann diese reden auch zu
protokoll geben können und hiermit würde
ich jetzt die aussprache beginnen und
als erstes hat das wort die kollegin
dagmar schmidt für die gruppe behrens
janitschek und andere
und diese brücke ist die utopie für eine
allgemeine impfpflicht bau und jetzt
modifiziert für die impfpflicht ab 60
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen allein gestern
wurden über 200.000 neuinfektionen
gemeldet knapp zweieinhalb tausend
menschen kam wegen und mit kur wird ins
krankenhaus
340 menschen sind daran gestorben
das ist immer noch sehr und viel zu viel
aber es scheint trotz alledem aufwärts
zu gehen darum geht es heute aber nicht
es geht nicht um das was ist sondern um
das was mit sehr hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit im nächsten herbst
und winter sein wird und wofür wir heute
vorsorge treffen
vorsorge dafür dass wir wieder steigende
infektionszahlen haben und dafür dass
die alten wieder kommen oder es neue
virusvarianten geben kann wir werden im
herbst wieder vor der gleichen
herausforderung wie letzten herbst
stehen das virus wird nicht einfach
verschwinden und wir wollen vorsorge
betreiben das gesundheitssystem die
kritische infrastruktur vor allem aber
die gesundheit der mensch zu schützen
und entweder wir haben dann die
impflücken weitestgehend mit unserer
beratungs und impfpflicht geschlossen
dann werden wir eine grundimmunisierung
in der bevölkerung die einen
weitestgehend normalen umgang mit dem
virus zulässt haben und dafür sind wir
oder die impflücken wird nicht
geschlossen und wir haben weiterhin
viele millionen menschen die keine
vollständige grundimmunisierung mit drei
büros kontakten haben und müssen dann
wieder maßnahmen ergreifen masken
abstand kontakt beschränkungen bis hin
zur schließung je nach schwere des virus
auch dafür auch dafür liebe diese
freiheitseinschränkung in kauf zu nehmen
kann man sich entscheiden oder wir
lassen es laufen mit allen konsequenzen
kranke tote überlastung des
gesundheitssystems der kritischen
infrastruktur und was mit longo wird
noch in gänze auf uns zukommt das wissen
wir noch gar nicht auch dafür kann man
sich entscheiden
ich rate dann nur besser nicht krank zu
werden und keinen unfall zu haben
und darauf will ich hinaus
man kann sich nicht gegen etwas
entscheiden ohne sich für etwas anderes
zu entscheiden wann trägt hier also
immer für das eine oder andere die
verantwortung und wenn man an der einen
oder anderen stelle liebe union sei es
eine beratungspflicht sei es eine
altersgrenze sein ist datengrundlagen
sein ist entscheidungsmechanismen an im
krieg ist wenn man andere vorstellungen
oder ideen hat dann gibt es in einer
demokratie das bewährte verfahren der
verhandlung und des kompromisses und
diesen kompromiss haben wir mit ente
ullmann und seiner gruppe gefunden und
er sieht wie folgt aus erstens gegeben
der beratung der aufklärung und direkten
ansprache eine chance und führen eine
beratungs nachweispflicht für alle ab 18
1 das kann ab sofort geschehen und wir
werden dafür werden um die
entsprechenden möglichkeiten abschaffen
zweitens wir sorgen für den herbst vor
mit einer impfpflicht für die über 60
jährigen damit schützen wir das
gesundheitssystem
und
schließen die impflücken vor allem bei
der besonders wohlhabenden
und drittens sorgen die perspektivisch
für eine große ruhe grund immunität alle
erwachsenen als voraussetzung für ein
normales gesellschaftliches leben
entweder dadurch dass die beratung und
aufklärung wirkt mit dem schwerpunkt
zunächst auf den über 60 jährigen und
einem bericht dazu ende mai wenn das
nicht wirkt dann bleibt es bei der
impfpflicht mit kontrollen ab und
nachweis erbringen bis herbst und dann
im herbst nicht gestattet zwischenfrage
aus der
zirkulation der afd nein nein und dann
im herbst mit einer entscheidung für die
18 bis 59 jährigen auf grundlage eines
berichts über impflücken virus mutation
erwartbares infektionsgeschehen und so
weiter so dass es dann in einer
schwierigen situation eine impfpflicht
auch für die über 18-jährigen mit
einfachen beschluss geben kann und wir
über eine breite immunisierung bändern
auch etwas später aus der dann
schwierigen pandemischen lage
herauskommen werden noch ein
grundsätzlicher satz zum abschluss
putins krieg gegen die ukraine wird
weitere folgen haben die menschen in
unserem land unsere wirtschaft der
erhalt von arbeitsplätzen unser
sozialstaat werden vor große
herausforderungen gestellt wir haben
heute die chance im herbst nicht auch
noch mit den maßnahmen zur pandemie
bekämpfung zurecht kommen zu müssen
darum bitte ich um ihre zustimmung
[Applaus]
also für den gesetzentwurf
die modifizierung bedeutet dass die
pflicht als 60 1 geschafft werden soll
im herbst aber alle sollen beraten
werden erwachsen und wenn das bis zum
herbst nicht ordentliche quoten treibt
dann soll auch ab 18 noch mal abgestimmt
werden ob da nicht eine impfpflicht
gehört jetzt einer kurzintervention
vielen dank frau präsidentin frau
kollegin ich bin 63 jahre alt ich bin
zweimal geimpft worden und ich hatte vor
zwei wochen eine krone erkrankung zwei
tage fieber das war es die behauptung
diese impfung würde in irgendeiner weise
also vor der erkrankung schützen ist
damit nachweislich falsch
bedauerlicherweise habe ich auch mehrere
mitglieder meiner familie mit dem virus
angesteckt die behauptung die impfung
würde also in irgendeiner weise vor der
ansteckung anderer menschen schützen ist
damit ebenfalls nachweislich falsch das
einzige was klar und beweisbar ist dass
eine impfung wenn sie dann durchgeführt
wird im allerbesten fall für drei monate
eine schutzwirkung entfaltet wenn es
überhaupt eine schutzwirkung gibt und
dann ist es damit vorbei und das macht
das ganze in höchstem maße absurd denn
was heißt das wenn diese
zwangsimpfung von ihnen durchgesetzt
wird das heißt dass ich mich selbst wenn
ich mich dann noch einmal impfen lassen
würde zum dritten mal es eine vierte
eine fünfte eine sechste impfung
benötigen würde und niemand auf der welt
nicht der gesundheitsminister nicht der
kanzler und auch sie nicht können mir in
irgendeiner weise eine zusage darüber
machen was das mit meinem körper machen
würde denn klar ist nur eins klar ist
nur dass es gegebenenfalls sehr schwere
nebenwirkungen geben kann die
möglicherweise viel schlimmer sind als
die korona erkrankung mit zwei tagen
fieber jemals sein könnten vielen dank
frau schmidt möchten sie ja wieder
[Applaus]
mit großer freude denn erst mal kann ich
dem kollegen sagen sie haben ihre im
pflicht erfüllt mit zwei impfungen und 1
mal gelesen haben sie alles das was wir
in unserer gesetzlichen waren
erreicht und ich sehe es geht ihnen gut
das freut mich nochmal zur aufklärung
unsere impfpflicht bezieht sich auf drei
impfung oder zwei impfungen und einer
genesung weil das dann nicht davor
schützt dass man sich nicht nochmal
anstecken kann weil das aber davor
schützt dass man schwer erkrankt oder
daran stirbt
und weil wir dann in eine lage kommen
die in der gesamten gesellschaft für
eine so hohe grundimmunisierung sorgt
dass wir keine maßnahmen mehr brauchen
sondern dass wir anfangen können einen
normalen umgang mit diesem virus zu
pflegen das ist unser zutiefst
getragener wunsch dass wir endlich davon
loskommen mit diesem virus umgehen zu
müssen indem wir andere
freiheitsbeschränkungen auf uns nehmen
sondern wir wollen durch die
grundimmunisierung durch drei info zwei
impfungen und 1 mal gelesen schaffen
dass wir einen normalen umgang mit
anderen viren auch in unserer
gesellschaft tolerieren können und ich
würde mich freuen wenn sie nach ihren
eigenen erfahrung dann dem auch
zustimmen könnten
[Musik]
jetzt rufe ich den nächsten redner aus
auf den kollegen tino sorge für die
fraktion cdu csu die du sollst
gesundheitspolitische sprecher seiner
fraktion und die union liegt ein eigenes
einen eigenen vorschlag vor dass im
vorsorge gesetzt und ins register und
stufen plan steckt dahinter
ich muss sagen das was sie gesagt haben
kann ich nachvollziehen teilweise ich
finde es auch gut dass sie gesagt haben
wir müssen im rahmen der diskussion auch
über eine impfpflicht pro oder contra
oder in welcher ausführung aus form auch
immer wieder einen normaleren umgang
pflegen also dass das teilen wir als
unionsfraktion und deshalb finde ich es
gut dass sie auch wenn es die letzten
meter sind sagen wir hätten hier in
diesem hause aus dem aus der mitte aus
der mehrheit des parlaments eine
mehrheit finden müssen liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen und deshalb darf ich nur
noch mal um unseren antrag und muss dann
kompromissvorschlag aus unionssicht
werden sie haben ja gerade hier
dargestellt dass wir bei der frage der
bekämpfung im herbst vorsorge treffen
müssen wir haben deshalb als union einen
ausgewogenen vorschlag unterbreitet wir
sagen eben man kann bei der frage
impfpflicht ja oder nein nicht sofort
und gleich pauschal entscheiden ich sage
ihnen das ist wie bei der frage sind sie
bist du für die ehe ja oder nein da kann
man nur sagen es kommt darauf an es muss
die richtige frau da sein es muss der
richtige zeitpunkt da sein und es müssen
die umstände passen liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen und wir reden hier über
eine impfpflicht wo ich ihnen sage
dass wir momentan
momentan glücklicherweise
sinkende inzidenz sein haben wo wir
momentan in den krankenhausbereich und
glücklicherweise keine überlastung
situation haben und wo wir momentan auch
überhaupt nicht wissen was ein herz für
eine variante basiert wir wissen nicht
ob die impfstoffe im herbst dann so gut
funktionieren wie sie funktionieren
sollten und deshalb haben wir als union
gesagt lasst uns doch zuallererst eine
belastbare datengrundlage machen
stichwort ins register ich finde es gut
dass sie diesbezüglich jetzt auch sagen
wir müssen das machen aber es ist
natürlich kein kompromiss vorschlag wenn
sie in den gesprächen sagen wir sind
bereit das zu machen aber eben
irgendwann weil das der erste schritt
wäre und deshalb sagen dir im register
damit er überhaupt erstmal wissen wie
ist denn auch der eu status in der
bevölkerung und zweitens wir müssen
vorsorge für den herbst treffen und
diese vorsorge beinhaltet auch lieber
herr kollege gesundheitsminister dass
wir die impf infrastruktur vorhalten
oder kann es ähnlich sein dass sie in
allen bereichen lockern dass die masken
pflicht aufgehoben wird dass sie sich
aus der finanzierung der impfzentren der
länder zurückziehen wollen und hier
gleichzeitig mit macht eine impfpflicht
auf vorrat möglichst ab 18 durch die
hintertür durchziehen wollen das halten
wir für den falschen weg wie die
kolleginnen und kollegen versorger
gestatten sie
inzwischen merken dazwischen folge aus
der fraktion der grünen
bündnis 90 die grünen sehr gern
sie haben das wort
mehr bitte erläutern wie es gehen sollen
mitten in eine neue welle hinein die im
herbst hoffentlich nicht kommt aber nach
expertenmeinung mit überwiegender
wahrscheinlichkeit kommt dann eine impf
kampagne zu starten die noch erfolg hat
alle experten sagen wir müssen vorsorge
treffen wir müssen jetzt handeln in der
welle in der anstrengende welle ist das
einfach zu spät wenn sie uns das bitte
noch mal erklären wie das funktionieren
soll vielen dank
vielen dank herr kollege für die frage
das gibt mir die möglichkeit mal ein
paar dinge richtig zu stellen also wenn
sie hier sagen alle experten würden das
so sehen dann ist das nicht wichtig wir
haben immer gesagt wir müssen vorsorge
treffen und diese vorsorge treffen heißt
natürlich nicht dass wir jetzt pauschal
eine impfpflicht für alle menschen
beschließen oder in den letzten tagen
haben sie dann von der impfpflicht ab 18
auf 50 jetzt auch 60 umgeschwenkt sagen
aber gleichzeitig alle müssen dringend
sich beraten lassen was nicht nur
bürokratischer irrsinn ich wäre was auch
von den kommunalen spitzenverbänden was
von den kassen abgelehnt wird nein es
geht darum vorsorge zu treffen und wenn
wir wissen dass im herbst möglicherweise
einen eine welle auf uns zukommt dann
ist es doch umso wichtiger jetzt diesen
vorsorge mechanismus den wir vorschlag
in gang zu setzen es geht doch genau
darum wir können doch nicht sagen wir
nutzen ein mittel eine impfpflicht loch
dazu für alle personen wo wir wissen
dass aufgrund glücklicher weise milder
verläuft diese auswirkung des virus
komplett anders in den alters geworden
dann müssen wir schauen wenn wir die
überlastung das gesundheitssystem
vermeiden wollen wir wissen dass nach
jetzigen standpunkt gerade
überdurchschnittlich häufig eltern wenn
sie schwere verläufe haben auch die
intensivstation kommen können wir doch
jetzt nicht pauschal sagen wir zwingen
alle sich beraten zu lassen wir lassen
unabhängig von der dann im herbst
geltenden varianten ob das dann noch so
sein wird jetzt alle info wir wissen
dass das gar kein geeignetes mittel ist
und die meiner kollegin ich will ihnen
auch noch einmal ganz deutlich sagen das
irritiert mich seit wochen dass wir bei
der frage der eingriffe immer so lapidar
darüber hinweggehen naja es ist eben ein
grundrechtseingriff wir reden hier über
abwägung von grundrechten die reden über
eingriffe in die körperliche
unversehrtheit lieber herr kollege und
und das sage ich auch ganz offen in
richtung bundeskanzler in richtung
bundesgesundheitsminister ich hätte
erwartet dass bei dieser sensiblen frage
impfpflicht eingriff in grundrechte die
güterabwägung und die argumentation hier
klarer gemacht werden da muss in der
mitte des cholesterin gesprochen werden
und da kann man nicht sagen wir nutzen
ein mittel impfpflicht pauschal für alle
in dem wissen dass es zwar irgendwas
bringt ja impfen schützt impfen schützt
individuellen vor schweren verläufen
aber eine pauschale impfpflicht für team
nicht dazu dass wir mögliche überlastung
situationen verhindern die wir momentan
gar nicht haben deshalb nehme kollege
und kollegen stimmen sie dort für
unseren antrag das ist doch der
kompromisse in der mitte liegen wir
haben endlich ab 18
wir haben diejenigen die sagen wir
brauchen da keine impfpflicht und wir
als union haben gesagt lasst uns doch
die
vorsorgemaßnahmen treffen wenn
tatsächlich dieser fall eintreten sollte
was auch wissenschaftler sagen dass das
überhaupt noch nicht für diesen ist ob
tatsächlich im herbst ein gefährlicher
variante kommt aber lasst uns doch
vorsorge treffen und dann müssen wir
doch die impfzentren haben wir müssen
doch dann wissen in dem moment gibt es
diese variante haben die impfstoffe und
da können wir auch hier im parlament in
kürzester zeit entscheiden aber eben
nicht jetzt auf vorrat in dem wissen
dass es nicht das mildeste mittel ist
und deshalb liebe kollegen pflegen werde
ich inständig stimmen sie unserem antrag
zu
und jetzt haben wir in den letzten tagen
quasi auf den letzten metern gehört naja
warum es sei jetzt die union da nicht
kompromissbereit also ich kann - anbiete
kolleginnen und kollegen wir haben seit
wochen ein kompromiss auf den tisch
gelegt und sie können doch nicht ganz
sagt erwarten das wenn wenn sie es in
der eigenen hand koalition nicht
hinbekommen eine mehrheit für dieses
thema zu bekommen und wir diese arbeit
machen bei uns in der unionsfraktion wo
es auch ein breites meinungsspektrum
gibt dass dieser kompromissvorschlag von
ihnen nicht mal ansatzweise diskutiert
wird und dann erwarte ich von ihnen auch
dass sie ernsthaft auf uns zugehen und
nicht sagt lapidar na ja wir machen eine
impfpflicht jetzt das am 18 dann ab 50
jetzt ab 60 aber sofort und im register
irgendwann also insofern auch für
diejenigen die hier noch unentschlossen
sind liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir
wissen doch alle es ist ein sehr
komplexes thema wir haben alle
individuelle betroffenheit wir haben
eine meinung wir haben uns alle eine
meinung dazu gebildet wir wissen wie
hoch polarisieren dieses thema in der
gesellschaft diskutiert wird deshalb ist
es doch an uns mit einem ausgewogenen
kompromiss mit augenmaß die
voraussetzung zu schaffen das im herbst
diese welle ihn nicht kommt oder
bekämpft werden kann und dafür ist unser
vorschlag ein wirklich tragfähigen
kompromiss vorschlag wir strecken ihnen
die hand entgegen öffentlicher hand
schließlich
vorschlag zu dann werden die haupt im
herbst gewappnet sein in diesem sinne
danke für ihre unterstützung und vielen
vielen dank liebe kollegin auch
dass wir das was wir in den debatten
immer gesagt haben ich habe es in einer
debatte gesagt wir sollten uns die tür
zur versöhnung offen halten liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und egal wie
unterschiedlich die meinung sein möchten
wir haben also nun einen vorschlag
unterbreitet wir strecken die hand aus
stimmen sie diesen vorschlag zu dann
werden der für den herbst gut gewappnet
sein können die debatte befrieden und
die polarisierung aus der gesellschaft
in vielen herzlichen dank
timo sorge wahr dass der
gesundheitspolitische sprecher der cdu
bundestagsfraktion
er hat gewarnt dass der antrag diese
schmitt und co zu einer impfpflicht auf
vorrat 18 werden würde münchen bei der
rede also ein bisschen schiene vergessen
zu haben dass die union jetzt in der
opposition ist aber der hinweis dass der
antrag der opposition in der union gut
sei und die anderen um mit stimmen
könnten das ist ja durchaus legitim
alles weil jetzt auch die fdp hatte
einen eigenen antrag hier heute
vorgelegt nämlich abschaffen
das grundgesetz hat den zweck die
freiheitsrechte der bürger zu
garantieren
unter diesen wichtigen und grundlegenden
rechten rad das recht auf leben und
körperliche unversehrtheit
hervor das ist unsere letzte
verteidigungslinie wenn eine regierung
sich anmaßt dieses höchste recht nach
belieben umzubiegen dann brauchen wir
keinen verfassungsschutz mehr um zu
sagen dass diese regierung
verfassungsfeindlich handelt nämlich
dass nicht nur radikal
verfassungsfeindlich
sie ist eine totalitäre anmaßung eine
entwürdigung des individuums der einzig
argumentative gruppe für die endlich ist
eine art kollektive notwehr weil du mich
angeblich mit deinem körper
gefährdet hast du das recht verwirrt
über diesen frei entscheiden zu dürfen
ich zwinge dich daher zu deinem glück
eine furchteinflößende
sichtweise
bahn stellte menschliche körper denn
keine gefahr mehr dar nach der dritten
nach der vierten nach der fünften
impfung wer entscheidet das und wer gibt
dem staat das recht und zu unserem
angeblichen glück zu zwingen
weil der befürworter klüger sind als der
rest
ausgerechnet die erste berufsgruppe die
von der freiheitsfeindlichen impfpflicht
betroffen ist sind ärzte krankenpfleger
altenpfleger die im übrigen den schaden
in ihren job kündigen
also diejenigen die das größte wissen
haben es geht also nicht um wissen um
das abwägen von rechtsgütern sondern um
die luft an der uneingeschränkten
verfügungsgewalt schon der lock down war
eine politik vorbei am faktischen nach
unserer freiheit ist jetzt unser körper
an der reihe
die erwachsene sind keine konventionelle
impfstoffe sondern einen quantensprung
in der wissenschaft keiner dieser
wirkstoffe hat eine reguläre zulassung
das sind millionen teuren werbekampagnen
als peaks zu verbuchen ist eine
infantilisierung der bürger die eine
rechtliche entmündigung vorweg reif
berechtigte bedenken werden nicht
argumentativ sondern pseudo moralisch
begegnet der einzig rational
nachvollziehbare grund für eine
impfpflicht sind die millionen impfdosen
auf den professor lauterbach sitzen
bleibt das aber sind die probleme eines
überforderten gesundheitsminister nicht
unsere die regierung trifft
entscheidungen ohne zuverlässige daten
grundlage es gibt keine belastbaren
zahlen zum im status zu nebenwirkungen
oder zu hospitalisierung tragen
hinzu kommt dass mittlerweile sogar
doppelt geimpfte in der statistik als
ungeimpft gelten wenn ihre letzte
impfung ein halbes jahr zurückliegt an
impfstatus für ein halbes jahr da gibt
es jetzt die regierung zu dass die
impfung nicht taut
zahl chaos auch bei der erfassung von
impfnebenwirkungen
es mehren sich die zeichen und ich
möchte dass sie das ganz nehmen hier es
mehren sich die zeichen für eine
dramatische unter erfassung von
gravierenden gesundheitsschäden durch
die neuartigen mba vakzine diese fälle
sind keinesfalls
die universitätsklinik marburg eröffnete
eigens eine spezialambulanz die
überläuft dort gibt es wartelisten von
über 800 patienten hunderte e-mails am
tag das unwürdige impfpflicht geschacher
der ampel ist deshalb nicht nur blamabel
es ist verantwortungslos
sie wolle mit ihrem es nicht gesetzt das
gesundheitsministerium ermächtigen jede
gesetzesänderung ohne abstimmung im
bundestag durchzuführen
die impf nicht ab 60 dient ihm lediglich
als trojanisches pferd sie ist in
wirklichkeit die impfpflicht für alle
verlogener geht es nicht
wolfgang kubicki hat den antrag seiner
gruppe vorgestellt
ebenfalls ein fdp abgeordneter der
gesundheitsminister andrew ullmann
er hatte mit einer gruppe 45 personen
stark die impfpflicht ab 50 gefordert
aber erst im herbst nämlich erst dann
wenn die verpflichtende beratung für
alle ungeimpften zu keinen ergebnissen
steigerung der in führung führt und dann
sollte in der bundestag entscheiden im
herbst impfpflicht
50 aber andere ullmann und seine gruppe
sind um gesprengt haben sich darauf
eingelassen mit der gruppe wiese und co
zusammenzugehen nämlich eine allgemeine
impfpflicht ab 60 ist als komponist
herausgekommen andere uli
ziel unseres gesetzentwurfs ist ganz
klar wir wollen vorsorge treffen wir
wollen keinen dritten corona im vorchor
winter erleben wie bis letztes jahr voll
ist es ja erlebt haben wir wollen
endlich frei sein in dem wir auch unser
gesundheitssystem stütze und lieber
wolfgang es geht uns hier nicht um
selbstschutz sondern es geht um
fremdschutz wir wollen unser
gesundheitssystem vor überlastung
schützen das funktioniere nur wenn keine
probleme
zwei damen und herren wir
stehen vor einem entscheidungs dilemma
nichtsdestotrotz eine vorhersage wie die
welle im winter aussehen wird können wir
seriös eigentlich nicht vorhersagen wie
wissen die welle kommt aber die qualität
dieser welle kennen wir wirklich nicht
das eigentlich mehr eine
wettervorhersage aber dass sie
kommentiert ist klar wir brauchen noch
bessere datengrundlagen das ist auch
keine frage und diese werden wir auch
bekommen und während auch entsprechend
diese auch berichten lassen aber was
sollen wir jetzt machen um diesen
nächsten winter in einer katastrophe
nicht enden zu lassen nix machen stand
der dinge heute ist das sicherlich eine
möglichkeit wäre aber ein pokerspiel das
haben wir letztes jahr bereits erlebt
nichts machen hat dazu geführt dass wir
wieder nach den daten das wollen wir
nicht
wir wollen auch nicht aus dem bauch
heraus in eine entscheidung treffen weil
es sich gut anfühlt nein wir wollen ein
wissenschaftlich fundierte gegenmittel
einbringen um dieses gegenmittel ist
ganz klar im flug beschließen denn nur
so kommen wir durch die nächsten tagen
dann stellt sich die frage wie gut reden
brachte bislang wenig impfpflicht ja da
müssen wir aber natürlich prüfen
inwieweit auch mildere möglich mildere
mittel möglich sind das ist eine
professionelle ärztliche aufklärung der
ungeimpften die bürgerinnen und bürger
sind
aufklärungswürdig und sind auch
vernünftig und so können wir auch
unseren kunden erhöhen unser
ursprünglicher gesetzentwurf aus unserer
gruppe wollte dies aber wir waren die
kleinste gruppe wir hatten keine
mehrheit und wir hatten sie auch nicht
haben wiederholt versucht kontakte zu
machen hat leider nicht funktioniert
aber die mehrheit der antragsteller
renata stelle unserer gruppe wollte
heute nachmittag nicht mit leeren händen
dastehen sollen wir waren
kompromissbereit wir haben einen
kompromiss gesucht wir sind auf die
gruppe der allgemeine impfpflicht gruppe
zugegangen wir als gruppe der
aufklärungspflichten
ein kompromiss gefunden in den teilen
ist es natürlich auch schmerzhaft weil
unsere idee wir immer noch für die beste
halten aber wir können natürlich nicht
ohne irgendetwas heute noch da stehen
und deswegen möchte ich danke sagen für
die verhandlungsgruppe und auch die
kollegen kollege unsere ursprünglichen
gruppe
starten zwischen bemerken
die fraktion das ist durchaus
therapeutisch dann kühlen sich unter ich
las es dazu
so welcher kollege war es denn von ihnen
beiden es war so viel auf ok sie haben
das wort
ich möchte sie
als 72 jähriger
der sich nicht hat impfen lassen
und bis heute durch die pandemie die
sogenannte durchgekommen ist ohne
irgendetwas groß zu haben ich hatte vor
drei wochen
und nicht für zwei sondern für drei tage
diese omikron variante und war dann
wieder heile und konnte dann in
sachsen-anhalt mich testen lassen und
die sache war erledigt ich war nicht
krank aber ich habe leute gesehen die so
standen
nach der impfung die wochen lang
behandelt werden mussten nehmen sie zur
kenntnis wie viele menschen es gibt die
deswegen angst haben vor dieser impfung
weil diese ihm vor auf viele menschen
krank macht und es gibt gutachten das
0,4 prozent der leute die geimpft werden
0,4 prozent mit dem tode sogar bedroht
sind wie können sie dann über eine
allgemeine impfpflicht überhaupt noch
sprechen beim solchen
grundrechtseingriff ich fahre sie auch
davon abstand zu nehmen und kripo klasse
regeln dass wir in deutschland ein
freiheitliches land sind und dass wir
ein rechtsstaat sind und eine kreishaus
überbelastung hast überhaupt nicht
gegeben entschuldigen sie bitte das ist
so heftig werde aber ich mache mir
sorgen die impfung kann nämlich auch
mich umbringen wenn ich die machen muss
und ich werde mich auf keinen fall
impfen lassen das sage ich ihn wirklich
da zahle ich lieber ein bußgeld schluss
aus hören sie auf damit lassen sie die
menschen in freiheit leben
kollege bleiben sie bitte kollege
bleiben sie bitte stehen
danke aber sie dürfen sich auch
hinsetzen was sie bisher erreicht und
das ist gleich auch besser sind
ich möchte ich finde sie am einige
wichtige punkte eingebracht wie will man
konstruktiv an die sache herangehen sie
haben ihre eigene beobachtungen mit
ihrem eigenen körper gemacht so läuft
klinische wissenschaft leider nicht weil
das würde
ich freue mich riesig dass sie mit ihrem
alter mit 72 ankurbelt interaktion so
milde durchgemacht haben das wissen wir
auch dass gibt auch die wissenschaft her
80 prozent der menschen haben einen sehr
milden verlauf und das ist auch gut so
und das ist auch mein spiel durchaus
roulette damit oder pokalspielen ist es
nicht gut zu spielen aber das legt sich
impfen lassen möchte oder nicht aber
eine sache muss man hier klar sagen wir
haben jetzt nicht eine allgemeine
impfpflicht hier in unserem kompromiss
stehen sondern wir haben eine
impfpflicht ab 60 als kompromisslösung
gemacht mit scharfstellung oktober
darf ich mal zu ende sprechen ja ich
habe ihn ja auch zu ende sprechen lassen
und somit haben sie eine möglichkeit und
wir haben auch die möglichkeit zu sagen
wenn die korona krise so weiter läuft
bisher und auch die whu sagt er durchaus
ist könnte milder werden können indem
ich schon verlauf haben aber dafür sind
jedoch hier im bund ist doch so
entscheiden die pflicht da ist kein
problem wir können das jederzeit
entscheiden nur jetzt müssen wir uns
vorbereiten wird dieser winter nicht
ausprobiert
nur inter noch nicht fertig sie haben ja
auch gesagt leute haben angst vor der
impfung das ist genau der punkt die
leute die angst und sorge haben vor der
impfung nehme ich als sehr ernst die
müssen aber aufgeklärt wird nicht durch
ihr mich
prima gruppen oder displays book gruppen
oder sms die man bekommt oder telegramm
gruppe aus der afg sondern eine
professionelle
und dann kommt
aber ein dass sie behauptet dass die
impfung unsere freiheit zerstört ist
wirklich zu kurz gesprungen ist ein
bisschen blind in der
menschheitsgeschichte
was bisher immer so eine anämie endet
dann eine bevölkerung immunisiert ist
und die egalisierung der
wirtschaftsgeschichte war immer tod und
krankheit damit verbunden wir haben
jetzt erstmalig in der
menschheitsgeschichte die möglichkeit
mit einer impfung dieses teufelskreis zu
durchbrechen
und sie setzen ihre freiheit sagen das
ist meine freiheit ich halte ich nichts
von gesellschaftliche verantwortung denn
sie von freiheit sprechen sie davon
qualitative freiheit sprechen nicht eine
sammlung von ihrem verhalten
in unserem antrag und das biete ich
jetzt auch an steht tatsächlich die
aufklärungspflicht an erster stelle
steht sehr dankbar dass die gruppe und
seine gang gekommen ist im pflicht haben
wir für die besonders von arabien unter
60 jahren mit schachteln oktober der
bundestag erhält regelmäßig
wissenschaftliche berichte über stand
der akademie global auch national und
somit auch die möglichkeit der
aussetzung oder auch erweiterung der
impfpflicht und das ist weitsicht mit
weiß ich komm mir vor der welle und
lieber unions kolleginnen kollegen es
gibt keine blaupause in der pandemie
bekämpfung nur gemeinsam können wir
diese pandemie bekämpfen reißen sie die
mauer ein land des parteichefs reißen
sie die mauer des pastors es ein und
lassen sie ihr gewissen sprechen unser
gesetzentwurf ist ein angebot an sie
alle dankeschön
gesundheitspolitiker der fdp er ist
selber arzt und weiß wovon er redet er
hat sich bewegt hat sich der anderen
gruppe angeschlossen es geht nämlich
darum hier eine mehrheit zu finden und
android man argumentiert ist es wichtig
die menschen zu beraten und gerade die
gefährdeten menschen ab 60 können dann
auch ab dem oktober alle geimpft werden
das schützt sie das ist die
argumentation
dieser gruppe jetzt also wieder wagen
sie ist sie die unser land und unser
gesundheitssystem auf die kommenden
monate vorbereiten und ich muss ehrlich
sagen es wäre schon wünschenswert
gewesen wenn die debatte und das
verfahren in dieser wichtigen frage
anders gelaufen wäre
stattdessen ist doch ein gewisses wir
war entstanden das wirrwarr hat damit
begonnen als sich die
regierungsfraktionen in gruppenanträge
geflüchtet haben statt ihrer
verantwortung gerecht zu werden und mit
einer stimme einen tragfähigen
gesetzentwurf einzubringen
dass sie mit diesem vorgehen nicht
weiterkommen und die gefahr besteht dass
sie am ende ohne eine lösung da stehen
war von beginn an absehbar und ein
völlig falsches signal und wo wir schon
beim falschen signalen sind möchte ich
doch auch einmal sagen herr kollege
lauterbach dass es aus meiner sicht
angebrachter gewesen wäre in der
aktuellen lage werden die verhandlungen
laufen mit den kollegen gemeinsam um
einen mehrheitsfähigen gesetzentwurf zur
innenstadt wieder bis spät in die nacht
bei markus lanz zu sitzen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir als cdu csu waren nicht untätig in
anders als sie haben wir vor wochen
einen der aktuellen lage angemessenes
konzept vorgeschlagen hinter dem steht
unsere fraktion und von dem sind wir
überzeugt wo keine klare linie erkennbar
bei war bei ihrem lavieren in den
letzten tagen das in der sache schon
unwürdig war von einem vorschlag von
einer impfpflicht für über 50-jährige
und einer impfpflicht ab 18 ist jetzt
ein vorschlag einer impfpflicht ab 60
geworden wie das rechenbeispiel noch zu
vermitteln ist weiß ich auch nicht und
wo da eine güterabwägung stattgefunden
haben soll erschließt sich mir auch
nicht
wir lassen uns lieber herr kollege dr
ullmann auch nicht vorwerfen dass wir
nicht kompromissbereit waren oder dass
wir hier allein aus parteitaktischen
gründen mit ihrem vorschlag nicht
mitgehen 1
wir gehen aus guten gründen nicht mit
unser antrag ist aus unserer sicht der
beste weil er der einzige ist der lage
um sachgerecht ist er bietet auch alle
künftigen entwicklungen
der pandemie eine antwort hier und heute
eine impfpflicht zu einem festen datum
zu beschließen ist der aktuellen lage
verfrüht und unverhältnismäßig wären
mildere mittel zur pandemie bekämpfung
wie die massen pflicht einfach auslaufen
lässt der kann heute parallel dazu
keinen tiefgreifenderen
grundrechtseingriff in form einer
impfpflicht einführen
müssen
impfen ist zwar nur ein pieks aber es
ist auch ein körperlicher eingriff und
eben nicht lapidar daher muss sorgfältig
abgewogen werden und das tun sie nicht
und damit hat sich die ampel selbst in
eine sackgasse der rechtsunsicherheit
manövriert
fremden geschützt
impfen schützt insbesondere vor schweren
verläufen allerdings droht momentan
keine überlastung des gesundheitssystems
deshalb ist aus unserer sicht aktuell
keine impfpflicht angezeigt aber wir
müssen vorbereitet sein vorbereitet
falls der pandemie verlauf zum beispiel
durch eine tödliche variante eine
impfpflicht erforderlich macht und
deshalb müssen wir schon heute ein
rechtssicheres gesetz schaffen das die
voraussetzungen für einen passgenauen
impf mechanismus der zukunft
sicherstellt dass genau liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen tut unser
antrag ist eben keine starre impfpflicht
auf vorrat die aufgrund der heute
unklaren pandemie entwicklung völlig
ungeeignet ist liebe kollegen
kollegin backen das starten sie noch
auch wenn sie nur eigentlich nur noch
drei sekunden hätten aber eine
zwischenfrage aus der spd-fraktion gern
herr rose man
ja frau kollegin waren dass man vielen
dank dass zwischen frage zu lassen
vielleicht können sie die frage
beantworten die der kollege von bündnis
90 die grünen vorher im herrn sorge
gestellt hat die er überhaupt nicht
beantworten konnte
sie sprechen ja von
vorsorge passt zum namen ihres kollegen
aber hat passt leider nicht zu dem
antrag also erklären sie mir doch mal
erklären sie doch mal wie sie wie sie
eigentlich sicherstellen wollen dass
wenn ihre impfpflicht vorsorge die
eventuell dann greifen soll wenn die
krankenhäuser schon voll sind dann soll
sie in kraft treten dann beginnt es dann
müssen die bürgerinnen und bürger drei
impfungen durch machen die mit einem
gewissen abstand ja durchgeführt werden
müssen erklären sie doch mal wie diese
wie dieses verfahren tatsächlich
vorsorge sein soll wenn das am ende erst
greift also die leute erst dann geimpft
sind wenn die welle dann schon wieder
rum ist
klar beim herr kollege die frage müssen
sie sich selbst stellen ob sie mit dem
was sie hier vorschlagen in der
aktuellen welle auch irgendetwas
bewirken können überhaupt zum einen zum
anderen
zum anderen kann ich kann ich nur noch
einmal betonen dass herr kollege sorge
dass ihr glaube ich schon dass sie dir
dargelegt hat und man einfach auch mal
den antrag lesen kann das würde glaube
ich helfen
zu verstehen
und es hilft uns am ende auch kein
gesetz das dann von karlsruhe wieder
kassiert wird weil es nämlich zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt
unverhältnismäßig ist weil der
grundrechtseingriff eben nicht
gerechtfertigt ist zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt und sie haben sich ja ziemlich
schwer getan mit der einführung zb eines
im krieg ist das was aus unserer sicht
essenzielle voraussetzung ist um
überhaupt auch mal eine datenlage zu
haben auf die man dann aufsetzen kann
auf die man die menschen auch gezielt
anschreiben kann dann ist nämlich auch
keine beratungspflicht für diejenigen
leute die eh schon sagen ich lasse mich
nicht impfen da brauche ich auch keine
beratungspflicht man muss aber gezielt
menschen an schreiben auffordern
informieren deswegen haben wir auch
gesagt ist im register wichtig da haben
sie sich ja lange gesperrt und haben das
aus datenschutzgründen und was auch
immer
abgelehnt aber man braucht eben solche
mechanismen um vorbereitet zu sein und
das sagen wir wir müssen uns vorbereiten
müssen besser vorbereitet sein und
deswegen unser antrag der jetzt schon
die weichen stellt dann wenn es soweit
ist tatsächlich umgesetzt zu haben das
dann auch rechtssicher ist ein gesetztes
zwar jetzt verabschiedet wird aber am
ende nicht
keine wirkung entfalten kann weil es von
den gerichten wieder kassiert wird das
hilft uns glaube ich überhaupt nicht
ich darf aber abschließend frau
präsidentin noch einmal befragen und der
kollege sorge hat auch schon betont die
union bleibt gesprächsbereit lassen sie
uns doch gemeinsam das suchen noch eine
gute lösung und einen guten kompromiss
für unser land zu finden herzlichen dank
lima warten hat die frage beantwortet
verfassungsrechtlich sieht die union
probleme bei der leichten variante jetzt
diesen grundrechtseingriff vorzunehmen
im übrigen führte das in österreich dazu
dass die dortige impfpflicht tatsächlich
ausgesetzt wurde ich gerne schwimmen
jetzt gesundheitspolitiker der
bündnisgrünen er ist für die allgemeine
impfpflicht und jetzt für den
modifizierten antrag im pflicht ab 60 ja
sagen lieber kollege sorger vielleicht
lassen nämlich mit einer bemerkung vorab
staaten demokratie besteht nicht daraus
dass man einen wirkungslosen
halbfertigen antrag in den raum wirft
dann die tür verschließt und nicht mehr
ans telefon geht sondern demokratie
besteht daraus ein gesetzesentwurf
vorzulegen in verhandlungen zu gehen
kompromisse zu schließen hier im
parlament
sie lassen nicht hinbekommen
nach vier monaten intensiver debatte in
der gesellschaft und im parlament zur
frage ob es eine impfpflicht als
vorsorgen das instrument raus aus der
pandemie geben soll ist heute der tag
der entscheidung ich lege mit vielen
abgeordneten aus oppositionsfraktionen
und den regierungsfraktionen einen
funktionierenden gesetzentwurf vor der
eine impfpflicht ab 60 entfernt vorsieht
der wirksam ist der rechtssicher ist und
der vernünftig ist als arzt möchte ich
ihnen sagen weil die frage gerade
nochmal aufkamen dass die altersgrenze
dabei keineswegs willkürlich ist sondern
mit medizinischer bedacht und evidenz
gezogen ist zwischen 50 und 60 jahren
steigt das risiko für einen schweren
verlauf noch einmal extrem an das heißt
eine impfpflicht ab 16 erfülle 60
erfüllt zwei ziele zum einen schützt es
die besonders gefährdeten menschen und
es schützt unser gesundheitssystem von
neuerlicher überlastung und uns alle vor
einem weiteren pandemie herbst und
winter deshalb verdient dieser
gesetzesentwurf ihre stimmen liebe
kolleginnen kollegen
die pandemie ist eine von mehreren sind
multan krisen mit denen wir in unserer
zeit aktuell konfrontiert ist und die
beste krisenpolitik ist krisenprävention
nach zwei jahren pandemie nach
flutkatastrophe nach energie
abhängigkeit von einem russischen
diktator möchte ich mir in der
gesundheitspolitik nicht mehr vorwerfen
lassen keine vorsorge getroffen zu haben
vorsorge heiß dafür zu sorgen dass die
pandemie im herbst und winter nicht
wieder unser öffentliches leben lahm
legt vorsorge heißt heute zu handeln um
die freiheit von morgen zu sichern die
prävention mit der impfpflicht bringt
uns raus aus dieser pandemie aus guten
gründen soll es bei dieser medizin
ethischen frage keine fraktionsdisziplin
geben wenn ich aber nun höre dass
unionsabgeordnete intern schriftlich
aufgefordert werden nicht über
impfpflicht ab 60 mit ja zu stimmen dann
habe ich den eindruck die union benimmt
sich bei einer besonderen gewissen farbe
besonders gewissenlos neben dem virus
das menschenleben tötet gibt es in der
politik offensichtlich ein virus der
parteitaktik und dieses virus der
parteitaktik tötet das vertrauen in
demokratische institutionen wir haben
alle in diesem parlament eine gemeinsame
verantwortung für dieses land gegenüber
den menschen die mehrheitlich weiterhin
nach vier monaten eine impfpflicht
wollen wir haben die verantwortung jetzt
vorsorge für den herbst zu tragen liebe
union auch sie stehen in der
verantwortung besinnen sie sich darauf
und stimmen sie für den gesetzentwurf
der vorliegt
nachdem hier mit einer klaren abrechnung
der unions haltung in der tat hat die
fraktionsführung der union die unions
abgeordneten aufgefordert für ihren
unions antrag zustimmen so weit so gut
und wenn es dafür keine mehrheit gibt
hat die unions führung verlangt dass die
abgeordneten keinen anderen antrag zur
mehrheit verhelfen sollen wenn heute
alle vorlagen scheitern dann wird weiter
verhandelt werden martin sichert jetzt
ist von heftigen ein echter demokrat
macht nach der wahl was er vor der wahl
versprochen hat heute
heute ist der tag an dem die bürger
sehen welche abgeordneten demokraten
sind vor der bundestagswahl hat jede der
im bundestag vertretenen parteien den
wählern versprochen dass es keine
impfpflicht geben wird jede einzelne
hier vertretene partei hat dieses
versprechen im wahlkampf gegeben für uns
von der af de ist die demokratie
grundlage unseres handelns als
überzeugte demokraten
als überzeugte demokraten werden wir
nach der wahl halten was wir vor der
wahl versprochen haben in dem wir
geschlossen gegen eine empfiehlt stimmen
es ist an der zeit all die lügen zu
beenden auf denen die gesamte corona
politik fust justizminister buschmann
lockt als er sagte dass zum 20 märz alle
maßnahmen enden werden maßnahmen sind
noch da gesundheitsminister lauter
machtlos als er ende oktober sagte dass
es keinen booster für alle brauche und
er drei wochen später den booster für
alle forderte einfache abgeordnete wie
emilia fester logan als sie verkündete
dass sie nicht im ausland war obwohl sie
urlaub in dänemark gemacht hat aber
aber wie kann man es den bundestags
flügen zum vorwurf machen wenn selbst
der bundeskanzler liegt olaf scholz
schlug als er im dezember erklärte dass
die regierung nichts von schweren
nebenwirkungen der impfung erfahren habe
zu dem zeitpunkt waren laut der
bundesregierung knapp 30.000 fälle
schwerer nebenwirkungen registriert das
ist immerhin die bevölkerung einer
mittelgroßen stadt
herr scholz ist nicht da ist wo wir
gehen meine rede anscheinend geflüchtet
aber ich denke mal er schaut heimlich
draußen im fernsehen zu herr scholz sie
haben den bürgern vor der bundestagswahl
gesagt zitat wir brauchen keine
impfpflicht wollen sie wirklich auch
dieses wahlversprechen brechen und als
lügen kanzler in die geschichte eingehen
ja die nächste lüge die nächste lüge kam
von jens spahn er sagt wir nämlich die
impfung sei ordentlich zugelassen das
ist die impfung bis heute nicht es gibt
nur eine bedingte zulassung der ema die
bis
2024 eine ordentliche zulassung prüft
jeder der ein medikament nimmt das nur
bedingt zugelassen ist der nimmt an
einem medizinischen experiment teil und
ein medizinisches experiment ein
medizinisches experiment darf niemals
verpflichtend sein dass
das sagt nicht nur die allgemeine
erklärung der menschenrechte die
europäische grundrechte charta das
grundgesetz sondern das sollte auch
jeder bundestagsabgeordnete aus der
deutschen geschichte gelernt haben daher
fordere ich sie alle auf
daher fordere ich sie alle auf schließen
sie sich uns an zeigen sie dass ihnen
die demokratie was wert ist und stimmen
sie gegen die impfpflicht
martin sichert war das für die afg die
einen eigenen antrag vor legt eine
ablehnung der impfpflicht und die
abschaffung der berufsbezogenen pflicht
werden darin gefordert der nächste
redner ist
noch nicht gesichert werde ich sie jetzt
für zwei dinge rügen sie haben einmal
gesagt weil es zwei persönliche angriffe
gegeben hat und das will ich jetzt auch
nochmal einmal erklären sie haben einmal
die kollegin emilia fester als
bundestags typen bezeichnet
das ist eine mögen sie lachen das ist
aber einen angriff in der person und
eine diskutierte äußerungen dafür ruhig
sie hier
und das zweite ist sie haben den
bundeskanzler in der person als lügner
bezeichnet auch dass auch das ist eine
angriff es ist ein angriff auf die
person und auch dafür erteile ich ihnen
eine rüge
es ist ein das diskutierte zu ihn nicht
sondern dass es hier mit noch mal
festgehalten und jetzt rufe ich
demnächst die nächsten redner auch für
die gruppe behrens und janáceks drk
lauterach
lauterbach redet jetzt hier als
abgeordneter für eine gruppe nämlich die
die impfpflicht wollte das wollte ja
auch immer als
bundesgesundheitsminister und jetzt
redet als abgeordneter nächste mal sehr
viele zögern hier im haus ob eine
impfpflicht noch notwendig ist weil die
omikron variante milder verläuft als
frühere varianten ich möchte dazu sagen
romy kommt ist deshalb eine etwas
mildere variante war so viele menschen
schon geimpft sind wenn es nicht so wäre
wenn es wenn sich alle 40 halle wenn
sich alles so verhalten hätten erst hier
zum teil vorgetragen wird und niemand
hätte sich impfen lassen dann hätten wir
jetzt eine lupenreine katastrophe und
während im völligen loch das muss man
verstehen und
herr kollege politik alle varianten die
bisher gekommen sind sind von experten
nicht vorhergesagt wurden sie haben uns
aber eben vorgetragen was im herbst
kommt sind sie bescheidener ich schätze
sie ich gebe in literatur die zeit es
sind durchweg sehr gefährliche varianten
möglich wenn die omikron variante zum
beispiel tiefer in die lungen abschnitte
geht das sind noch fünf oder sechs
mutation dann haben wir eine sehr
ansteckende sehr gefährliche warnte
davor haben namhafte kollegen angst und
sie sollten nicht vortäuschen als wenn
sie wissen dass das im herbst nicht der
fall ist
dann starten wir eine klage von der
kollegin baum aus der stadt ein
ich möchte ausdrücklich auch darauf
hinweisen
dass wir selbst wenn die omikron
variante im herbst zurück ins camp keine
andere wahl hatte sie würde nicht
gefährliches mehr genauso wie erst dann
hätten wir im oktober nach allem was die
modelle her gehen ungefähr 200 bis 300
todesfälle wie jetzt wollen wir das
wirklich als gesellschaft akzeptieren
wollen wir uns daran gewöhnen dass jeden
tag 200 300 menschen sterben und wollen
wir uns erzählen dass das einzelne
möglich gehabt haben und davon ableiten
dass andere auf der intensivstation
lägen nun um ihr leben kämpfen das kann
keine humane gesellschaft für uns
und wir haben es in der hand ich
appelliere noch einmal an die
kolleginnen und kollegen in der union
wir haben es in der hand an ihnen wird
viele leute hängen sie können dann dass
sie können der verantwortung nicht
ausreichend in dem sie sagen sie sind
gesprächsbereit die gespräche haben über
monate stattgefunden heute ist der tag
der entscheidung lassen sie uns nicht im
stich unterstehen sie wenig ist elisa
verantwortung wählen sie die ich nicht
wollen dann sagen sie es hier sind
abgeordnete im parlament von denen nicht
nichts oder so gut wie nichts erwarte
die sagen aber klar was sie wollen aber
sind sie ehrlich sie wollen die
impfpflicht oder nicht wir brauchen
heute einmal ihre starts fragen
unterstützung um im herbst anders dazu
stehen was wir jetzt stehen
und ich will zum schluss die wichtigste
zahl sagen die richtig integrieren und
sterben abgeordnete aus jahren erstanden
hat es angedeutet habe ich sage es und
wir sind da einer mal die wichtigste
zahl ist heute 90 prozent werden wir die
impfpflicht ab 60 beginnen dann
verhindern wird 90 prozent der
todesfälle die wir mit einer impfpflicht
verhindert hätten 18 wir haben heute die
möglichkeit 90 prozent der todesfälle
die vermeidbar sind durch an endlich zu
vermeiden nutzen mir bitte diese
gelegenheit
lauterbach als abgeordnete der
bundeskanzler mehr waren für eine
impfpflicht für alle haben aber keine
mehrheit in den ampel fraktionen und
deswegen haben sie das ganze verfahren
an die parlamentarier abgeben müssen und
nun sind sie in der tat darauf
angewiesen eine mehrheit zu bekommen
bei der union jetzt eine
kurzintervention der abgeordneten baum
vielen dank herr lauterbach ich bin 66
jahre und habe bis heute mein leben in
eigenverantwortung verbracht privat wie
wirtschaftlich ich bin zudem zahnärztin
und stehe jeden tag in den sogenannten
spree neben in den aero sohlen und habe
bis heute diese zwei jahre und drei
monate ohne irgendeine infektion
verbracht weil ich ein sehr gutes
eigenes immunsystem haben wer in ihnen
nun das recht nicht zu entmündigen nach
einem so langen erfolgreichen geben wir
geben ihnen recht und mit welchen
gewissen können sie es überhaupt
vereinbaren nachdem sie heute wissen
wieviel schweren nebenwirkungen und
todesfälle es durch diese impfung gibt
wie können sie es überhaupt noch
vereinbaren mit ihrem gewissen und das
trage ich alle anderen abgeordneten auch
wenn mir oder anderen personen die durch
ihren zwang sich jetzt nötigen lassen
diese impfung zu geben wie können sie es
verantworten wenn den personen etwas
passiert oder wenn sie sogar sterben das
möchte ich gerne von ihnen wissen
dankeschön
herr lauter was sie möchten erwidern
muss ehrlich sagen ich finde es immer
wieder bestürzend und zum glück ist es
selten aber ich finde es immer wieder
bestürzend wenn kolleginnen und kollegen
aus der medizin und wie gesagt es sind
wenige ihre reputation als ärztin nutzen
um etwas zu sagen was vor der gesamten
wissenschaft der welt in abrede gestellt
wird mir wir verlassen uns wir sind
durch diese krise gekommen in der wir
uns auch die wissenschaft verlassen hat
in den menschen vertraut haben die
verfahren gegangen sind und gerade die
ärzte wir sollten uns zuerst intern
lassen wir sollten mit beispiel fragen
geht denn die menschen vertrauen und
dieses vertrauen sollten wir nicht
ausnutzen warnte lauterbach kämpft ihr
bis zur letzten minute und auch der
bundeskanzler tut das denn die
reputation von beiden hängt natürlich
auch an dem abstimmungsergebnis heute
soeben meldet eine agentur dass die
außenministerin annalena baerbock
vorzeitig vom nato-treffen abreißt auf
wunsch des bundeskanzlers erwünscht dass
sie hier an der abstimmung teilnimmt da
sieht man mal wie knappe
mehrheitsverhältnis sein können und wie
wichtig das ganze hier auch für den
bundeskanzler und andere durchaus ist
max lux jetzt er spricht für die kubicki
interaktion dieses hauses
sie können ihre lügen hier wider
besseren wissens verbreiten sie werden
nicht verhindern können dass die
demokratischen abgeordneten heute im
respekt voreinander in dieser sehr
schwierigen gewissensentscheidung eine
entscheidung treffen
ich halte es für erforderlich die impf
lücke zu schließen aber ich komme zu der
abwägung
gegen eine impfpflicht zu sein
ist komme
ich komme dazu weil meine erfahrung als
freund und verwandter in dieser pandemie
der in seinem umfeld um die impfung
einer jeden einzelnen personen gekämpft
hat mir zeigt dass es nur dann
funktioniert wenn man den druck raus
nimmt ich halte die erklärungen dass
eine impfpflicht zur schließung der imf
lücke führt nicht für plausibel denn
eine pflicht doubt normativen druck auf
ich halte diesen normativen druck für
den falschen weg liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
die impfpflicht verspricht viele
menschen ein pandemie ende per gesetz
doch ich befürchte dass sich dieses
versprechen nicht halten lassen wird
stattdessen wirkt sie rechtliche
gefahren ich mache mir sorgen dass der
ausschluss von ordnungshaft
verfassungsbeschwerden nicht standhält
und individuelle gesundheitliche gründe
durch das normative raster fallen können
die umsetzung dieser pflicht ist nicht
sichergestellt und ein nicht umsetzbares
gesetz bringt uns in der pandemie nicht
weiter liebe kolleginnen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir haben als
parlament und als politikerinnen und
politiker in der frage wie wir menschen
vom impfen überzeugen in der frage die
die gesellschaft zusammenhalten nach
dieser und in dieser pandemie so viel
mehr spielräume als nur ordnungsrecht
lassen sie uns diese nutzen lassen sie
uns die impfpflicht zu den akten legen
dankeschön
max lux ein eher junger grüner
bundestagsabgeordneter der nicht für die
impfpflicht ist also der antrag im wiki
und jetzt eine andere grüne abgeordnete
nämlich paul empire schotter sie ist
ursprünglich den vorschlag von dem mann
gewesen beratung und hilfe nicht ab 50
und hat sich jetzt dem antrag
angeschlossen dem pflicht ab 60 sehr
geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir treffen
heute dieses schwierige entscheidung vor
zwei ziemlich einfachen wahrheiten eine
wahrheit ist niemand von uns kann
wirklich vorhersagen wie corona sich in
diesem herbst darstellen wird auch der
gesundheitsminister nicht das komplett
richtig die andere wahrheit ist auch wir
haben den letzten und dem vorletzten
corona herbst verschlafen wir waren
nicht ordentlich vorbereitet und wir
haben deswegen auch die interessen
unserer bevölkerung nicht ausreichend
gut geschützt und das darf uns einfach
nicht noch einmal passieren wenn wir
alle in verantwortung genommen
aber wir sehen heute in dieser debatte
in kondensierter form und war an welchen
punkten auch im letzten und dem
vorletzten ja genau diese vorsorge
gescheitert ist im sommer jetzt gerade
wieder im frühling wenn die wände kroner
pandemie nicht das wichtigste thema ist
wenn die öffentliche aufmerksamkeit
nicht komplett auf dieses thema
gerichtet ist da wird zerredet der wirt
beteiligt vorgeschoben der wird darauf
vertröstet dass man ja noch zeit hat bis
zum herbst und dann ist es wieder zu
spät und deswegen schauen wir uns mal an
was jetzt heute hier auf dem tisch liegt
bei dem versuch diesen fehler nicht zum
dritten mal in folge zu machen und ich
las beiseite den stoß von rechts und ich
las auch bei seite des ins politische
werbung bermudadreieck um herrn kubicki
frau wand nicht und herr gysi ich finde
da da muss man jetzt keine zeit
verschwenden aber dann schauen wir uns
jetzt mal den unionsantrag an der
unterhofer antrag sagte stuft der imf
mechanismus was steht bei uns im
gesetzentwurf erst mal eine impfpflicht
tatsächlich kann ausgesetzt werden im
sommer im herbst wenn sie nicht
gebraucht wird kann aber auch zu
gestalten werden das ist gestuft die
union möchte neben register des ins
register formaten steht bei uns im
gesetzentwurf
die union möchte auf der basis von
wissenschaftlichen daten auch zu den
neuen varianten entscheiden da steht bei
uns als wissenschaftlicher bericht für
den herbst genau mit drin die
inhaltlichen unterschiede zwischen ihrem
antrag und unserem gesetzentwurf die
sind so klar in die erlauben keine nicht
zustimmung von ihnen wissen
[Applaus]
wie begründen können und dann müssen sie
hier mehr sie waren nicht dabei aber die
meisten hop kollegen haben 16 jahren
regiert wenn man den versucht jetzt
wieder frei im brief die zu bitten den
impuls zu unterdrücken zuzustimmen damit
was rauskommen ich übersetztes mal sie
bitten ihre fraktion den impuls zu
unterdrücken konstruktiv zu sein das ist
aber die dna der union
[Applaus]
ich verstehen aber die eben nicht der
aktion gegeben den ganzen land einst mit
sie geben ihren leuten in den ländern
und den kommunen 1 mit hendrik wüst
und auch daniel günther die haben alle
in den letzten tagen noch mal gesagt das
ist das braucht natürlich gehe jetzt mit
ihnen noch mal ne runde drehen wir
können noch mal über endlich kompromisse
sprechen aber die zeit läuft davon und
wenn wir irgendwas die letzten zwei
jahren gelernt haben ist dass man nicht
unendlich viel zeit bis zum herbst wenn
man vorbereitet sein sie starten sie
einen zwischenstand
die spitzenfunktionen
ich gestalte zwischen frau kollegin sie
haben das wort
vielen dank dass sie die zwischenfrage
zu lassen weil sie jetzt so tun als wir
da keine unterschiede und die union ist
schuld dass sie nicht mitmachen ich
nehme an dass sie keine juristen sind
sondern ärztin und vom herzen des
helfens argumentieren und leider immer
noch in diesem rechtsstaat auch die
verfassung halten ist ihnen bewusst dass
es einen völligen unterschied gibt
zwischen einführung einer pflicht jetzt
noch nicht verfassungswidrig aber wenn
man seine branche muss er halt wieder
aus wir haben noch nicht die
voraussetzung wir schaffen die
voraussetzungen aber wenn dann die
voraussetzungen vorliegen erst dann kann
man durch einen erneuten parlament
beschloss eine impfpflicht einführen das
sind verfassungsrechtlich dimensionen
[Applaus]
dieser unterschiede auch bewusst es ist
ungewohnt des verfassungsgerichtes dazu
führt dass all diese gesetze nichtig
sind tun sie nicht so als wäre es völlig
irrelevant des verfassungsrechte geht um
grundrechtseingriff
vielen dank für die frage ich
entschuldige mich werde der eindruck
entstanden sein sollte dass ist das
verfassungsrecht ignoriert das tue ich
keinesfalls wer mir in den letzten
monaten ausfiel ist auch mit diversen
verfassungsrechtler ihnen gesprochen und
alle haben sagt letztendlich ist alles
was heute hier auch zur abstimmung liegt
in irgendeiner form vor dem
verfassungsgericht auch argumentierbar
das ist eine politische entscheidung sie
können jetzt hier nicht sie können jetzt
hier nicht das verfassungsrecht
vorschieben die müssen
auch
gewählt von vielen menschen die partei
auch von älteren menschen die darauf
vertrauen wenn sie im herbst einen
herzinfarkt oder schlaganfall haben dass
sie dann dass sie dann darauf vertrauen
können dass alles dafür getan wurde dass
das gesundheitssystem da nicht
überlastet ist und sie ohren nicht
versorgen und dann werden auch sie
gemessen werden und deswegen noch mal
unter mit
das ist eine entscheidung wo man nicht
der ampel was mit gibt wo man nicht der
spd oder herr lauterbach was mit gibt
sondern wo man dem ganzen land was mit
gibt wenn man jetzt nicht das erkennt
was notwendig ist sagt mathis muss
antiquitäten auch gerne
manchmal zu pragmatisch sind aber wenn
ich mir die letzten zwei coroner jahre
anschaue dann brauchen wir mehr
pragmatismus und nicht weniger
rockig schütter nimmt sich die
taktische spielereien verfuhr er redete
ein fraktionskollege von ihr der war
ganz gegen die impfpflicht und das ist
ja das dilemma dass teile der ampel
fraktionen nicht mitstimmen wollen bei
den großen antrag gegen allgemeine
impfpflicht die jetzt nehmen novelliert
wurde in pflicht ab 60 ja so der nächste
redner
ist erhält stofer richelsdorfer von der
cdu csu bundestagsfraktion
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
im grundsatz glaube ich sind wir uns
einig wir wollen die pandemie besiegen
und jetzt geht es darum was der richtige
weg ist und wir haben heute die
möglichkeit
dass wir ein vorsorge gesetz beschließen
das uns die chance gibt dass wir es
rechtlich das wäre es handwerklich gut
vorbereitet und
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren ich
mag es nicht wenn man hier so in die
glaskugel schaut keiner von uns hat die
gewissheit und weiß es wirklich was im
kommenden herbst und im winter geschehen
würde und
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
unser vorschlag gibt die möglichkeit und
das ist hier ein bisschen zu kurz
gekommen dass die evaluierung der lage
fester bestandteil unseres vorschlags
und
und ich glaube dass es wichtig ist dass
wir ständig informiert werden über die
situation in den krankenhäusern dass wir
ständig informiert werden über die
infektions lage dass wir ständig wissen
was denn sache ist und dass wir dann
ordentlich entscheiden können und meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren ich
möchte hier schon noch mal aufhören so
zusammen und auch auf die frau dr
gehörte eingehen sie ist meistens hier
vor dass wir irgend jemand etwas
mitgeben wollen oder dass wir
parteipolitisch handeln und dass es eine
gewissensentscheidung ist meine sehr
geehrten haben den herren ich möchte
ihnen schon mal sagen wenn sie hier
diese form der gruppe anträge für
richtig halten ja warum machen sie dann
die gruppen anträge nicht bei anderen
sachen aus der not heraus machen sie
gruppenanträge weil sie sich nicht einig
sind das ist ob ich die wahrheit die
hier zum glück sehr geehrten nahmen
und wenn wir dann doch gerade über focus
online hören dass bundeskanzler scholz
verburg auch fordert sie solle doch das
nato-treffen früher verlassen weil sie
zur abstimmung zu impfpflicht kommen
soll naja ich glaube das spricht bände
meine verehrten damen und herren
kollegen
ich habe
sie sehen
ich glaube aus der fraktion der grünen
aber auch aus der fraktion die linke
zwei wünsche nach einer zwischen bemerke
und dazwischen frage lassen sie die zu
verstehen
dann würde ich mit der fraktion mit den
kollegen aus der fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen beginnen
wir haben ja viel gemeinsam wir teilen
uns hier einen wahlkreis und auch die
kommunalpolitische erfahrung vor ort und
was wir lernen wir dass das ziel im
fokus steht dass wir gemeinsam an einer
sache arbeiten wie bewerten sie denn
dass dieser impuls den ja jeder
politiker jeder politikerin hat das ziel
die sache zu stellen jetzt ausgebremst
würde durch ihre politische
geschäftsführung und gesagt wurde auf
keinen fall dürfte konstruktiv
beteiligen am prozess und eine lösung
mitarbeiten in diesen dingen
herr kollege eckhard ich möchte ganz
klar stellen dass und mein vorredner der
herr sorge auch das ja auch noch mal
betont dass die union jederzeit
gesprächsbereit ist aber es muss
natürlich schon vom willen getragen sein
auch das richtige zu tun das ist
notwendig und bass leiterin
die zweite war die kollegin vogler aus
der fraktion die linke
lieber kollege irlstorfer sie haben hier
die
regierungskoalition dafür kritisiert
dass sie diese
dieses anliegen in gruppen anträgen
behandelt das habe ich auch getan weil
ich der ansicht bin dass ein
gesetzentwurf für eine allgemeine
impfpflicht durchaus von der
bundesregierung hätte vorbereitet und
vorgelegt werden können
das aus ihrem mund kommt man ja doch ein
bisschen seltsam vor weil es war doch
gut gelebte praxis der cdu csu fraktion
in verschiedenen in den letzten 16
jahren immer dann wenn sie sich selber
nicht einig waren zwischen der csu und
der cdu zum beispiel oder wenn sie in
der fraktion unterschiedliche auffassung
hatten auch gruppen antragsverfahren
vorzusehen zb bei der organspende da
kann mich noch gut daran erinnern da war
ich ja auch daran beteiligt also ich
frage mich wirklich welche rolle die
union als größte oppositionsfraktion
hier in diesem parlament ein zu nehmen
gedenkt wenn die wenn sie die positiven
erfahrungen die wir doch auch mit diesen
gruppen verfahren teilweise gemacht
haben jetzt wo sie in der opposition
sind und wo sie die rolle des
oppositionsführers
schafft annehmen nun plötzlich nicht
mehr ernst nehmen und wenn ich dann lese
dass bei ihnen in der fraktion der
parlamentarische geschäftsführer
angeordnet hat falls ihr antrag keine
mehrheit findet und jetzt zitiere ich
sollte dem impuls widerstanden werden
anderen vorlagen zuzustimmen nur damit
es irgendein ergebnis geben
ich mich doch wo ist denn da das recht
und die pflicht der abgeordneten sich
aus eigener gewissensentscheidungen auch
eine eigene neue
[Applaus]
in meinem herzen haben
ja
unterschiedlichen auffassungen zu den
verschiedenen vorlagen ausgetauscht
miteinander diskutieren und die werden
ja heute frei entscheiden und frei
abstimmen jede und jeder nach ihrem
gewissen und das muss ihnen doch
körperliche schmerzen bereiten dass die
linksfraktion da demokratischer ist und
das als die cdu csu fraktion ist jemals
sein kann
dagegen vor gericht kommen körperliche
schmerzen
bereitet wir aktuell longo mit und nicht
hier ein verfahren oder sonst
irgendetwas und ich kann ihnen nur sagen
dass aufgrund dieser tatsache ich
weiterhin noch einmal bestärkt werden
dass man richtig und vorsichtig handeln
muss und ich kann ihnen nur sagen was
wir hier erleben ist ja schon eine
bizarre situation
sie werden uns hier jetzt vor dass wir
uns auch stimmen wir sind doch die
einzige fraktion gewesen wo wir selbst
bei uns in der lage waren überhaupt
einen vorschlag parat
was uns das jetzt vorwerfen finde ich
seltsam auf jeden fall nehmen es aber
zur kenntnis und ich kann nur sagen in
der vergangenheit ja da haben wir auch
von diesem instrument gebrauch
gemacht aber wenn sie jetzt sagen dass
dieses eine gewissensentscheidung ist
dann frage ich mich wo sich beim § 209
10 aber haben sie nicht noch einmal
keine dividende
also von daher
danke ich für die zwischenfrage mädchen
natürlich weiter fragen ich kann ihnen
nur eins sagen das liegt mir am herzen
es ist die situation so dass wir diese
debatte heute führen und die führen wir
so spät glaube ich und ich glaube auch
dass wir natürlich einem register
benötigen das ist wichtig ist es
notwendig und wenn wir zu einem ergebnis
kommen würden was eine impfpflicht sie
auf den weg bringen würde dann würde ich
mir schon auch wünschen dass es hier
ausfahrten gibt aus horten für menschen
die körperliche schäden haben wo ist
denn hier eine ausnahme regierung wo
sind denn hier die aufnahmen auch für
psychische situationen wo sind die
ausnahmen auch für das thema angst meine
verehrten namen werden wir
berücksichtigen wir verschiedene
gruppierungen von menschen überhaupt gar
nicht die vielleicht die familie einen
impfschaden haben und dort auch angst
haben dass sie sowohl verleiten das wird
nicht abgebildet das ist handwerklich
nicht in ordnung meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren
ich möchte nochmals darauf hinweisen
dass wir weder ein virus kennen das
verhärtete winter
dementsprechend uns vor eine neue
situation sind und dass wir auch noch
keinen impfstoff haben weil wir dass wir
es noch nicht kennen und deshalb lassen
sie uns hier wirklich mit weitblick und
mit augenmaß handeln wir wollen die
menschen schützen wir wollen wir im
leben schützen das ist das was uns
leitet vielen herzlichen dank
christopher war es der csu politiker
hatte hier das wort ging nächste
politiker die hier sprechen wort kommt
von der fdp kathrin helling klar die fdp
hat ja abgeordnete in allen möglichen
gruppen und an der fdp liegt es
natürlich auch dass es keine gemeinsame
ampel mehrheit geben kann denn viele
liberale sind gegen eine impfpflicht
katrin hering plan nicht sie war von
anfang an bei den verfassern der
allgemeine impfpflicht die jetzt wie
gesagt zunächst einmal impfpflicht ab 60
jahren fordern
der frau präsidentin meine damen und
herren
angst ist ein schlechter ratgeber erst
recht für politiker wir dürfen uns keine
angst machen lassen nicht von virus
pessimisten und auch nicht von corona
leugnen unsere aufgabe ist es die
situation
klug und vorausschauend zu bewerten so
da müssen wir eine lösung strategie
entwickeln und den mut haben für sie
einzutreten nach allem was wir wissen es
wird es im kommenden herbst winter zu
einer neuen corona welle kommen es
entstehen ständig auch in diesem moment
neue virusvarianten mit
unterschiedlichsten eigenschaften wenn
sich eine variante durchsetzt die
gefährliche als die jetzige ist dann
werden wir weihnachten wieder vor einer
situation stehen in der viele menschen
schwer erkrankten in der die kliniken
drohen überzulaufen
dann werden beschränkungen des alltags
wieder hochgefahren werden müssen es
wird kontakt beschränkungen und
einschränkungen sogar von gastronomie
und einzelhandel geben es kann sein dass
bildung und betreuung von kindern wieder
leiden menschen werden auch dringend
notwendige operationen warten müssen und
vieles mehr
man kann vor diesen nicht
unwahrscheinlichen szenario nicht die
augen verschließen
man kann sagen das ist okay für mich ich
lebe damit lassen wir die dinge laufen
dann braucht man unserem gesetzentwurf
nicht zuzustimmen oder man kann sagen
das risiko will ich nicht eingehen
nichtstun das passt mir nicht ich traue
mich vorausschauend zu denken und zu
handeln dann stimmt man unseren
gesetzentwurf zu nimmt ein segen heute
zur abstimmung stehen sind konzept gegen
einen weiteren pandemie winter das
konzept ist ein tragfähiger kompromiss
das ergebnis ehrlichen ringens um die
beste lösung mit einer vorgeschalteten
richtigen beratung all jener die sich
noch nicht zur impfung entscheiden
konnten räumen wir noch einmal mit
desinformation und fake news auf
beginnen der individuellen aufklärung
eine chance den impfungen sind der beste
individuelle schutz vor den folgen von
kogit vor schweren krankheitsverläufen
und tod mit dem frühzeitigen beschluss
eine impfpflicht für personen ab 60
jahren beugen wir eine überlastung des
gesundheitssystems wirksam vor und
darüber hinaus beobachten wir dass panik
die pandemie geschehen befassen uns als
parlament zuvor definierten zeitpunkten
und stellen so sicher dass wir stets auf
dem pfad der verhältnismäßigkeit bleiben
kollegen im winter behaupten man habe es
nicht kommen sehen kann dieses jahr
keiner mehr lassen sie mich deshalb
abschließend ihnen mit dem blick mit
blick auf die abstimmung gleich zu rufen
dürfen sie sich nicht weg auch wenn es
gegenwind gibt denn die sie
vorausschauend fassen sie den mut ihrem
gewissen zu folgen
vielen dank
klar von der fdp wird doch einmal für
die impfpflicht ab 16 und eine mögliche
in schlüchtern im herbst auch ab 18 wenn
bis dahin die impfzahlen nicht
hochgegangen sein werden das lehnt die
nächste rednerin die wir hier schon im
bild sehen im sahra wagenknecht von der
linken konsequent ab und sie mag froh
sein dass sie sich nicht dem hfg antrag
anschließen muss sondern dass mit
wolfgang kubicki ist eine gruppe gibt
die ebenfalls gegen eine zwangs in
pflicht ist aber
vor allen dingen die aufklärung will und
jeden einzelnen ermutigen will sich
impfen zu lassen mal sehen was sarah
wagenknecht dazu zu sagen hat
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen halten wir fest die impfstoffe
schützen nicht davor sich und andere zu
infizieren schwere verläufe sind mit
omikron zum glück so selten geworden
dass selbst trotz rekord incident sind
kein krankenhaus überlastet war wie gut
die impfung gegen künftige mutationen
schützt weiß kein mensch und dann häufen
sich auch noch berichte über
nebenwirkungen impfschäden und trotzdem
halten sie unbeirrt daran fest den
menschen eine impfpflicht aufzuzwingen
bei der kanzler durchsetzungsfähigkeit
demonstrieren muss weil ein kopfloser
gesundheitsminister der sich durch sein
erotisches ag längst unmöglich gemacht
hat zumindest in die
offenbar
handlungsfähigkeit und wir sichtbaren
will die deutschen geisterfahrer gegen
den rest der welt wo kein mensch mehr
über endlich nachdenkt und diskutiert
das kann doch nicht ihr ernst sein und
deshalb meine bitte hören sie auf die
menschen zu bevormunden die korona
impfung muss eine persönliche
entscheidung bleiben
ein schuss nochmals klargestellt sie ist
nicht grundsätzlich gegen eine corona
impfung insofern kann sie sich dem
antrag von wolfgang kubicki auch
franziska schenk von der spd hat den
antrag von dem man den ursprünglichen
unterstützt und jetzt also den
kompromissantrag mit der gruppe die die
impfpflicht ab 60
kollegen erleben ist eine ganze menge
selbst passen und manche sind auch des
lesens nicht so richtig mächtig aber
worum geht es denn ehrlicherweise die
ganze pandemie hat uns zwei jahre lang
mit ganze menge abverlangt besonders
familien kindern jugendlichen ich bin
mutter von vier kindern ich weiß wie es
ist neben der arbeit irgendwie noch
lehrerin zu sein zwischen familien- und
erwerbsarbeit zerrissen zu werden auch
ältere waren eingeschränkt manchmal sehr
einsam kranke kommt nicht ausreichend
behandelt werden unternehmen mussten
schließen menschen haben ihre arbeit
verloren
das gesellschaftliche leben kunst und
kultur fand nicht mehr statt zwei jahre
lang haben wir alle abstand gehalten
masken getragen kontakte minimiert das
motto war stets flirtende körper ich
danke all den pflegerinnen und ärztinnen
sowie allen freiwilligen die für ihren
riesigen einsatz nicht nur in der ersten
phase der pandemie sondern bis heute
dafür gesorgt haben dass unser
gesundheitssystem nicht zusammenbricht
und auch ohne die maßnahmen hätten wir
das alles nicht geschafft immer wieder
immer wieder diese einschränkungen der
grundrechte rechte und ausgebranntes
krankenhauspersonal das muss doch jetzt
mal vorbei sein und es kann vorbei sein
denn wir haben die mittel in der hand
wir haben fast alle fast alle die
möglichkeit uns impfen zu lassen doch
nicht alle nutzen sie also sind wir
heute hier und diskutieren über eine
impfpflicht ich danke unseren
gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach und
unserem bundeskanzler olaf scholz dass
sie diese so herausfordernde frage in
die hände des parlaments gelegt haben
es ist so lachen sie nur endlich und
dass ich an die cdu jeder und jedes
einzelnen abgeordneten
und lösungsorientiert abzustimmen und
unabhängig vom parteibuch es ist eine
gewissensentscheidung
die abgeordneten wir haben diskutiert
wir haben diskutiert nicht nur
miteinander sondern ganz besonders mit
bürgerinnen und bürgern und zwar sehr
lebhaft und sehr zu sehr
unterschiedlichen interessen
die debatte im parlament spiegelt das
heute glaube ich ganz gut wieder aber
unsere aufgabe als abgeordnete es ist
doch all diese interessen abzuwägen und
die impfung ist ein wichtiger schritt zu
gewohnter normalität gegen kuwait 19
gifte menschen haben nachweislich
mildere krankheit zum leute oder er kann
vielleicht gar nicht mehr und sie
bewahren unser gesundheitssystem vor
einer überlastung darum geht es die
schützen kommt in allen drei starken
einstellungen in der alle gemeinsam zwei
jahre lang getragen haben doch auch die
persönliche freiheit ist ein hohes gut
genauso die das gesellschaftliche
miteinander und ein funktionierendes
gesundheitssystem und zwar für alle die
es brauchen darum genau darum enthält
unser gesetzentwurf eine beratungs oder
impfnachweis pflicht für alle
bürgerinnen ab 18 und wir beraten auch
diese entscheidung kann man dann seine
eigene seine eigene entscheidung für
eine impfung treffen besonders erinnere
aber gruppen aber also menschen
tatsächlich müssen jedoch eine in die
nachricht vorzeigen und der bis zum
herbst nachkommen damit übernehmen sie
verantwortung unter ihnen auch weitere
grundrechtseingriffe das virus ist da
das virus wird bleiben lassen sie uns
heute für den herbst vorsorgen stimmen
sie heute für unseren gesetzentwurf
heutigen
system matschie von der spd die
diskussion dreht sich vor allen dingen
um die gruppen die besonders gefährdet
sind über 60 der sind im moment in
deutschland 2,7 millionen menschen die
sich einfach nicht impfen lassen wollen
das ist wesentlich mehr als in den
meisten europäischen anrainerstaaten
das kann man nur durch eine impfpflicht
lösen das ist die meinung vieler hier im
saal und auch die cdu ist durchaus für
eine impfpflicht in ihrem in vorsorge
gesetz das jetzt noch mal sehr müller
und ich appelliere insbesondere an
diejenigen die heute unentschlossen in
diesem parlament sitzen insbesondere aus
der ampel koalition sich unserem antrag
anzuschließen weil dieser ist vorsorge
der sie drei punkte vor wir möchten ein
impf register haben um zu wissen wer ist
denn überhaupt in unserem land gehen
wir wollen mit diesem ins register die
menschen anschreiben und darüber in
informieren welche möglichkeiten sie
haben sich impfen zu lassen und die
dritte möglichkeit zu schaffen dass wir
einen regelmäßigen bericht des
bundesgesundheitsministers hier im
deutschen parlament beraten und wenn
dieser bericht ergibt das eine
tödlichere variante kommt die
ansteckender ist dass wir dann natürlich
eine impfpflicht scharf schalten und das
ist vorsorge liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen und bitte schließen sie sich
unserem antrag an
herr müller
gestatten sie anfrage oder zwischen
bemerken aus der fraktion die grünen ja
stammen ja sie haben das wort verdammt
ja vielen dank herr kollege müller dass
sich die frage zu lassen ich würde gern
fragen wollen ob ihnen bewusst ist dass
es in unserem land erforderlich ist dass
damit regeln gelten ein gesetz
beschlossen werden muss und es nicht
ausreicht einen antrag hier im parlament
zu beschließen erster teil einer frage
und der zweite teil risiken bewusst dass
die drei
wesensmerkmale ihres antrags die sie
beschreiben nämlich dass es eine
verbesserte datengrundlage einen
regelmäßigen bericht eine befassung des
bundestages mit einem mechanismus der
aktivierung weitere altersgruppen
gegenstand einer abstimmung eines
gesetzesentwurfes heute hier im
bundestages ist und wenn dem so ist ist
der dritte teil meiner frage was hindert
sie daran genau diese wesensmerkmale
ihres antrags bis hin zum alter von 60
jahren heute mit einer unterstützung
hier im bundestag den weg zu ebnen weil
das wesen der vorsorge uns im beispiel
und bild zu machen ja darin besteht dass
man vor sorgt und nicht handelt wenn der
schaden eingetreten ist also die
feuerwehrwache bauten nicht wenn es
brennt sondern im vorfeld damit die
feuerwehr vorbereitet ist insofern warum
treffen sie heute nicht vorsorge für den
herbst mit einem gesetzesvorschlag der
vorliegt und regeln dafür sorgen
[Applaus]
danke er damit für ihre frage denn sie
gibt nochmal möglichkeit auch die
unterschiede klar zu machen sie haben
nämlich nicht die wesentlichen
bestandteile entnommen sie haben sich
weiteren gesprächen die wir angeboten
haben vor wert haben auf die tube
gedrückt haben auf die tube gedrückt und
diese abstimmung heute hier im deutschen
bundestag erzwungen und ich möchte ihnen
vor allem 2 ich möchte ihnen vor allem
die beiden bisher schön wenn sie mir die
frage stellen und zumindest an die
auch dabei zuhören könnten ich möchte
ihnen die beiden großen unterschiede
sagen sie möchten jetzt in ihrem antrag
der über nacht von 18 50 auf 60
verändert wurde eine beratungspflicht
einführen sie möchten diejenigen
verpflichten die noch nicht geimpft sind
sich beraten zu lassen währenddessen
ihre ampel koalition den ländern die
finanzierung für die impfzentren ab
mitte diesen jahres streicht wollen sie
dass ungeimpfte beraten werden sollen wo
sollen denn die das machen wo sollen die
denn das machen
wo soll denn die das machen dann kommt
ihre antwort was sie gerade zwischen
gerufen haben bei ärzten und apothekern
das kann man tun aber dann sind sie doch
so konsequent und zahlen den pflege
bonus auch den medizinischen
fachangestellten die vor ort nämlich
gerade die krankheit sei
krankenhäuser vor der überlastung
schützen punkt nur eins sie wollen die
beratungspflicht die wir nicht möchten
weil sie nicht umsetzbar ist das sagt
ihn auch nicht nur die gesetzliche
krankenversicherung sondern das sagen
ihnen auch alle kommunalen
spitzenverbände sie ist nicht umsetzbar
punkt nummer zwei
sie möchten eine impfpflicht heute
beschließen ab 60 und im zweiten schritt
dann für die 18 bis 59 jährigen das
unterscheidet uns sehr stark weil wir
sagen eine impfpflicht ist zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt weder verhältnismäßig noch
geeignet noch angemessen und ich sage
ihnen auch warum
ich sage ihnen auch warum
wir sehen in der aktuellen situation auf
den intensivstationen tatsächlich keine
überlastung durch corona infizierte wir
sehen aber eine überlastung auf den
gesundheits im gesundheitssystem durch
corona infiziertes medizinisches
personal
deswegen wird selektive deswegen werden
selektive eingriffe verschoben und
dieses medizinische personal ist geimpft
sie sehen also ihre impfpflicht die sie
jetzt beschließen wollen dient nicht dem
schutz zur überlastung des
gesundheitssystems sondern wir brauchen
dafür einen geeigneten impfstoff den wir
dann einsetzen wenn eine tödliche
variante kommt und vor diesem
hintergrund halten wir an unserem
vorsorge antrag fest sehr gerne
herr müller
forscher machen nehmen sie mann schlug
das kriegen wir hin es gibt noch eine
frage wunsch aus der spd-fraktion von
rolf mützenich sehr gerne da musst du
dich sie haben das wort
vielen dank frau präsidentin und der
kollege müller
vielleicht können sie verstehen warum
ich mich in diesem moment zu wort
gemeldet habe als sie hier behauptet
haben dass wir uns gesprächen die sie
uns bis zum schluss haben angeboten
verwerter ich möchte hier und ich hoffe
auch in mit ihrem einverständnis sie
können ja gleich darauf auch noch mal
antworten bezug nehmen dass wir mehrere
fach politische gespräche zwischen
einzelnen abgeordneten unter anderem mit
ihnen geführt haben und dass ich nach
dem 16
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten
der bundesrepublik deutschland uns
zweimal gebeten in einem beschluss der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
eine impfpflicht hier im deutschen
bundestag auf den weg zu bringen auch
das gespräch mit der union gesucht habe
und auch versucht habe kriterien zu
finden die ein weg das gemeinsame hier
im deutschen bundestag zu gehen ich wäre
ihnen dankbar wenn sie das zumindestens
heute hier in dieser debatte noch mal
richtig stellen würden das bis zum
schluss dieser weg versucht worden ist
dass am ende als wir aber kenntnis
bekommen haben das was der erste
parlamentarische geschäftsführer
den mitgliedern seiner fraktion zur
kenntnis gegeben hat offensichtlich und
sieht diese chance am ende verbauen
wollten was ich sehr bedaure
damit ziemlich
es ist ein klares bild welches nieder
zeichnen also ist deswegen ein sehr
schönes bild und wir haben
verschwiegenheit vereinbart in den
gesprächen aber eins kann man eins kann
man eins kann man sagen und das kann der
kollege das kann der kollege wiese
nachher sicher nicht bestätigen unsere
fraktion
ich war mit verhandlungsführer hat jedes
mal darauf hingewiesen dass unsere
fraktionsgremien darüber erst beraten
und dann weiter in das verfahren gehen
was hat ihre fraktion gemacht am
montagvormittag schickt ihr
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
11 19 eine e mail an alle abgeordnete
und setzt uns vor vollendete tatsachen
so geht man nicht miteinander und wenn
mal eine lösung des problems richter
punkt nummer 1 und nummer 2 mützel nicht
es ist ein sehr verschobenes bild
welches ihr zeichnen wenn sie die 16
ministerpräsidenten
erwähnen und dann vergessen den halbsatz
zu sagen welche kritik die
ministerpräsidenten an der bereits von
uns mitgetragen sektoralen impfpflicht
und deren durchführung haben dass die
kommunikation zwischen
bundesregierung insbesondere des spd
bundesgesundheitsministers und der
ministerpräsidenten überhaupt nicht
klappt und die kirsche auf die sahne hat
karl lauterbach mit der rücknahme der
isolations zeiten gemacht kommunikatives
desaster dieser ampel ist in japan die
politik fertig
herr müller sie
können wieder einen schluck wasser
trinken ich frage sie ob sie noch eine
zwischenfrage zu lassen von vor
hasselmann
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin wir haben
ausreichend redezeit ich denke ich komme
zum schluss damit wir auch die argumente
abwägen
sie können aber gerne zwischen
interventionen machen kolleginnen aber
lassen sie uns die argumente austauschen
lassen sich ihre redezeit jetzt wieder
weiter laufen und fahren in der debatte
fort vielen dank frau präsidentin
und deswegen geringen wir auch heute
deswegen ring wir auch heute in diesem
parlament um den richtigen weg
und wir haben viele wir haben viele auch
ausgewogene reden gehört ein paar lasse
ich mal außen vor
und darum möchte ich auch noch mal
ausdrücklich für unseren antrag werden
und vielleicht hätte die kollegin
hasselmann die frage gestellt die die
anderen kollegen gestellt haben was ist
das thema wenn sie später anfangen zu
impfen mit der ersten impfung wenn sie
später anfangen wollen zu impfen und
darauf möchte ich auch eine frage geben
gerade den unentschlossenen kollegen die
sich gerne unserem antrag anschließen
können
und kollegen denn selbstverständlich
aufweist
karl lauterbach hat am zweiten januar
dieses jahres
in einer sonntagszeitung
und am 13 januar diesen jahres vier im
parlament dafür geworben dass die
erstimpfung gegen den tödlichen verlauf
schützt und somit gegen die belegung der
intensivbetten und meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren das ist auch die
antwort auf ihre frage und gerade für
die unentschlossenen wenn sie unserem
antrag folgen wir vorsorge leisten ja
dann wissen wenn es eine tödliche
variante gibt die impfpflicht nach
kohorten beschließen dann reicht die
erstimpfung dazu aus das
gesundheitssystem nicht zu überlasten
und das ist geeignet dass es angemessen
und das ist verhältnismäßig
und nun ist der fokus heute auf dieses
parlament gerichtet und viele möchten
natürlich
diese debatte abschließen heute sie
wollen eine entscheidung wissen sie
wollen vorankommen
es kann aber am ende sein dass unser
antrag keine mehrheit findet und wir
deswegen auch keine mehrheit hier im
parlament sehen um unserem guten
vorsorge mechanismus vor zustimmen das
wird uns aber nicht davon abhalten ihre
kollegen sehr geehrter herr mützenich
dass wenn der rauch
verschwunden ist die türen auf sind und
das geht dann ab morgen gerne weiter und
wir für gespräche bereit stehen um uns
gegen die herbst werde zu schützen weil
das in frick ist da ist wichtig eine
dokumentation und ein anschreiben
diejenigen es wichtig die nicht geimpft
sind und ein vorsorge mechanismus dafür
zu treffen dass wenn eine tödliche
variante kommt wie auch dann eine
impfpflicht beschließen können vielen
dank
dirk müller war dass der stellvertreter
fraktionsvorsitzenden der cdu/csu ist
der letzte redner der union und der hier
nochmal auch durch die zwischenfragen
ausführlich die unions position
darstellen konnte hat das wort zu einer
kurzintervention rasen
würde man die fraktionschefin
meine damen und herren die argumentation
die gerade der abgeordnete müller aus
der cdu/csu-fraktion
hier dem parlament da gebracht hat heißt
ja wie folgt heute
darf es keine entscheidung in der sache
für eine impfpflicht geben
weil man aus prinzip und aus kritik an
herrn lauterbach oder wein an dass
sein buch kritisieren darf man heute als
abgeordnete nicht
selbstständig denken sondern
alle türen bei der cdu/csu wieder
aufmachen und weiter sprechen damit am
ende vielleicht im märz die krone auf
hat als kompromiss immer fahren
eine spiegelnde entscheidung zu treffen
eine wirklich schwerwiegende
entscheidung zu treffen in der sache wie
die cdu csu um noch für bündnis 90 die
grünen noch über die hp oder ein
gesundheitsminister
sobald für die menschen im land und für
eine woche
in der fraktion der öffentlichkeit diese
legende zu erzählt wir wären nicht
gesprächsbereit
und jetzt liegt ihre
verweigerungshaltung daran dass jung
montag um 11 uhr 11 eine nachricht
gekriegt seit vier monaten reden wir
über die einführung einer ecke
auch er ist in nordrhein westfalen der
bald eine landtagswahl vor sich hat
erwarten vom deutschen bundestag dass
wir im pflicht einführen und sie drücken
sich weg und die frage gesprächsangebote
meine damen und herren bei der hitze
nicht dazu geäußert habe ich kann nichts
dafür
ich kann nicht dafür dass der
fraktionsvorsitzende der cdu csu
nicht in der lage ist eine termin mit
der fraktionsvorsitzende von bündnis 90
die grünen zu finden
[Applaus]
die möglichkeit zu erwidern
möchte muss
[Musik]
[Applaus]
vor seiner
sie haben recht wir haben heute eine
sehr sachlich orientierte debatte die
wir wirklich geringen wir ringen in der
sache um die richtige lösung
und deswegen sind wir uns sicherlich
darüber einig dass hier keine trennung
in diesem parlament ist zwischen
moralisierend auf der einen seite und in
der sache in der sache eine
unterschiedliche auffassung zu haben auf
der anderen seite ich gehe davon aus
dass trennt uns nicht sondern ich sehe
auch in ihrer fraktion dass es
unterschiedliche meinungen gibt zum
thema antrag wäre als punkt nummer eins
punkt nummer zwei sie sprechen die vier
monate an vier monate
und sie erzeugen da und wollen damit ein
bild erzeugen dass unsere fraktion soll
locker meinen antrag hier hoffen sie
nicht da muss ich widersprechen
es war unsere fraktion die den
bundeskanzler und dem
bundesgesundheitsminister vor
weihnachten einen fragenkatalog zukommen
lassen der nicht beantwortet wurde es
war unsere fraktion habe man hier
bezüglich der allgemeinen pflicht dann
eine kleine anfrage gestellt hat die
nicht zeitgerecht beantwortet wurde es
war unsere fraktion die sich zuerst mit
expertinnen und experten zusammengesetzt
hat und dann über die allgemeine
impfpflicht um komplett der
fraktionsstärke debattiert hat und etwa
unsere reaktion der es gelungen ist als
volkspartei diese meinung zu einem in
einen antrag vorzutragen und dafür heute
auch zu werben damit wir diesen weg
gehen des vorsorge mechanismus und frau
sondern ihnen steht es frei sich uns
anzuschließen es wäre der richtige weg
nächster redner für die gruppe behrens
und janitschek und andere ist stefan
schwartze
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren ich
weiß nicht wie es ihnen geht aber ich
würde mehr über die sache und die
situation der menschen im land reden als
über das taktische hin und her und wer
wann mit wem hätte sprechen sollen
hätte ich heute morgen auch gerne eine
impfpflicht ab 18 beschlossen weil ich
sie für die beste vorsorge halte die wir
hätten treffen können
nur feststellen die hat leider keine
mehrheit
und darum wer habe ich heute umso
entschlossener für den jetzt vorgelegten
kompromiss einer impfpflicht ab 60 drei
punkte sind mir dabei ganz besonders
recht wichtig ich möchte jetzt noch die
bestmögliche vorsorge vor dem nächsten
winter treffen dabei ist impfen
unersetzbar und ganz besonders für die
älteren
lassen sie uns alles tun damit wir eine
überlastung im gesundheitssystem
vermeiden und die gibt es ich habe es
gerade noch in der letzten woche gehabt
dass bei mir vor ort im wahlkreis zwei
von drei krankenhäusern aus dem
regelbetrieb genommen worden weil das
personal erkrankt war und damit gibt es
eine ernsthafte situation für alle
menschen im kreis
wir
sollten solche situationen unbedingt
verhindern
und jetzt bitte ich sie einmal die
perspektive zu wechseln nicht hier als
abgeordneter sondern die perspektive von
patientinnen und patienten einzunehmen
viele menschen mussten seit der beginn
der pandemie
gering benötigte behandlung dringend
benötigte op zu verschieben
was bedeutet das für die menschen die
mussten mit weiter mit der krankheit
leben die mussten mit schmerzen leben
die mussten mit der großen ungewissheit
leben wann bekomme ich endlich meine op
was wird das ergebnis dieser op sein und
das hat spuren hinterlassen
und ich finde über diese menschen wird
viel zu wenig geredet und wir müssen
viel mehr in unseren diskussionen
stattfinden ja viele absicht gemacht wir
können an den zahlen ablesen
dass viel weniger menschen zur
vorsorgeuntersuchung gegangen sind
selbst
krebspatienten wird nicht zur nachsorge
gegangen um zur kontrolluntersuchung
soll man haben aus angst vor ansteckung
aus angst davor das gesundheitssystem
weiter zu belasten
auf diese wichtigen termine verzichtet
und ich denke auch die müssen wir in den
fokus nehmen
und ich habe mit vielen menschen geredet
die an den folgen der korona erkrankung
leiden die schwerwiegende folgen über
lange zeit ertragen müssen und auch die
möchte ich schützen das sind schwere
schicksale das kann ganze leben
zerstören und auch die müssen wir in den
fokus nehmen und darum bitte ich um
regen wir an die menschen die die op
verschoben haben denken sie an den
menschen die unter den langzeitfolgen
der korona infektion leiden und deshalb
stimmen sie unseren kompromissantrag zu
vielen dank
stefan sparte hat hier mal einen ganz
anderen aspekt gemüt der in der tat
hochinteressant ist wirklich viele
operationen müssen verschoben werden das
ist auch ein wichtiges problem gut dass
es hier auch zu wort gekommen ist der
nächste redner ist fraktionslos war bis
ende 2021 afd fraktionsmitglied jetzt
also einer von zwei fraktionslosen
abgeordneten im deutschen bundestag
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin die jetzt
wechselt liebe mitbürger
verfassungsrechtlich muss nicht das vom
grundgesetz geschützte
selbstbestimmungsrecht begründet werden
sondern immer die einschränkung der
freiheit das selbstbestimmungsrecht
verbietet es den einzelnen zu seinem
eigenen schutz zur impfung zu
verpflichten es kommt also lediglich
dass hier des fremdschutz ist in frage
die geeignetheit jegliche m pflicht es
dafür aber nicht gegeben weil die
verfügbaren cupid 19 impfstoffe keine
ausreichende immunität und damit keinen
ausreichenden fremdschutz erzeugen
menschen mit impfung sind bei einer
infektion nicht weniger anstrengend als
personen ohne impfung also kann die
impfung keine infektionsketten
unterbrechen sie immer weniger
gefährliche omikron variante zeigt
aktuell laut zwei dänischen kroaten
studien zur mrt wochenbericht das nach
wenigen wochen die ihm von keinen
positiven effekt mehr auf die
wahrscheinlichkeit ein effekt einer
infektion hat sondern die
wahrscheinlichkeit einer infektion sogar
erhöht die erforderlichkeit einem
vielleicht das ebenfalls zu verneinen
frau schmidt besonders angesprochen weil
spätestens mit den auftritten der
omicron variante die zahl der
erkrankungen mit schwerem verlauf das
niveau einer normalen saisonalen grippe
erreicht hat die impfung ist auch nicht
alternativlos wie uns der heute sehr
nervöser lauterbach immer noch glauben
lassen möchte denn es stehen heute
erfolgreiche mildere mittel wie bereits
verwendete und zugelassene medikamente
zur verfügung es gibt auch keine
signifikante überlastung des gesundheits
wie laut dass die wii registers amerika
betrug die mittlere belastung der
intensivbetten von patienten mit kubik
nur 9,5 prozent eine impfpflicht es
daher nicht verhältnismäßig weil die
verfügbaren bedingt zugelassen kubik 19
stoffe wieder fremd schützend noch
sicher vor risiken sind gemessen an der
gefährlichkeit und häufigen
nebenwirkungen die vom
paul-ehrlich-institut öffentlich
dokumentiert sind ein gesetz für eine
kopie 19 impfpflicht dafür eine folge
nicht verabschiedet werden auch nicht
auf vorrat da ist zum film schutz nicht
geeignet nicht erforderlich nicht
angemessen damit verfassungswidrig ist
frau präsidentin ich komme zum schluss
mit einem vorschlag unsere gespaltene
gesellschaft aber wieder etwas mehr zu
versöhnen dazu muss aber die
einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht wieder
aufgehoben werden und soldaten müssen
heute mehr denn gehe hinaus so behandelt
werden wie die mehrheit in diesem land
nämlich frei von jeglichen pflicht
vielen dank
johannes huber fraktionslos war hier der
letzte abgeordnete der nicht für die
impfpflicht plädieren wird in dieser
debatte denn die kommenden fünf
abgeordneten sind alle für die
impfpflicht und das gesetz impfpflicht
ab 60 die erste screening
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ja es stimmt
wir treten in eine neue phase der
pandemie ein endlich endlich wieder
kindergeburtstag ins schwimmbad gehen
abends mit freundinnen und freunde die
kneipe und ich gönne es von herzen gegen
der langsam wieder in diese normalität
zurück kommt und das dürfen wir auch
genießen aber wir dürfen darüber nicht
die vergessen für die diese normalität
noch meilenweit entfernt ist
[Applaus]
stellvertretend
stellvertretend dafür möchte ich heute
von einem mädchen hier aus berlin
berichten ich nenne sie jetzt mal daran
ara wird in wenigen tagen genau wie ihre
zwillingsschwester acht jahre alt sie
ist mit spina bifida also mit einem
offenen rücken auf die welt gekommen sie
haben entgegen alle ärztlichen
voraussagen doch laufen gelernt sie ist
eine kämpferin genauso ihre eltern und
doch ihre gesundheit ist weiterhin
fragil und wir wissen nicht was passiert
wenn sie jetzt corona bekommt für lara
und ihre geschwister und für alle
anderen staaten familien gilt kein
kindergeburtstag kein schwimmbad und die
eltern sitzen abends allein stadt mit
freundinnen und freunden in der kneipe
und das seit mehr als zwei jahren das
ist unsere verantwortung im blick zu
haben dass auch schüler
familie das recht auf freiheit gilt auch
belegen erlauben sie eine zwischenfrage
auf den fdp faktion
bitteschön frau kollegin vielen dank
dass er die zwischenfrage zu lassen
die frage ist ja wie ihr vorschlag
eigentlich administriert werden sollen
also sie schlagen eine beratungspflicht
vor sie schlagen eine impfpflicht form
wie soll das eigentlich technisch und
praktisch umgesetzt werden ich frage das
deshalb weil der wahlkreis ja in berlin
ist und berlin ist ja dafür bekannt dass
es besonders
lange dauert wenn man
administrative dinge vor ort machen will
ein personalausweis anmelden will was
sich ummelden will sie anmelden will
also teilweise dauert das ja wochen und
monate hier in berlin wie wollen sie
dafür sorgen dass das tatsächlich in
berlin auch umgesetzt werden kann
die werke lege vielen dank für diese
zwischenfrage ich weiß nicht ob sie das
wissen ich war bevor ich in den
bundestag gekommen in berliner
landesvorsitzende der grünen ich durfte
in dieser funktion auf
koalitionsgesprächen mit der fdp in
berlin führen das war leider nicht
erfolgreich ich muss aber sagen wir
haben eine sehr sehr gute zusammenarbeit
mit den linken in berlin deswegen ich
finde beide konstellationen sehr
konstruktiv und ich kann ihnen sagen wir
haben innerhalb der letzten fünf jahre
in der rot rot grünen koalition in
berlin massive fortschritte gemacht was
vorher die große koalition tut mir leid
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen unter
schwarz rot in berlin runter gerockt hat
ja sparen bis es quietscht
da haben wir wieder extrem viel aufbauen
können und wir sind noch nicht da wo wir
hinwollen aber wir haben sind wieder
rein und ich höre bei ihnen raus sie
wollen das als fdp auch im berliner
abgeordnetenhaus unterstützen das kann
ich nur befürworten herzlichen dank
dafür und ich bin mir sicher wenn wir
alle gemeinsam versuchen das gemeinsam
hin zu bekommen dann werden wir auch die
ämter entsprechend ausstatten können
diese beratungspflicht und dann die
impfpflicht wenn sie denn zieht auch für
die jüngeren gut gemeinsam umsetzen zu
können und ich freue mich auf ihre
unterstützung dabei
komm zurück zu mir redest ist unsere
verantwortung die familien im blick zu
haben auch für die gilt das recht auf
freiheit und deshalb ist es gut dass wir
heute über einen kompromiss
diskutierende ein weg eröffnet
vorbereitet in den herbst zu gehen und
damit besonders die zu schützen die es
brauchen es ist kein geheimnis dass ich
mich eigentlich für eine impfpflicht ab
18 eingesetzt habe mit blick besonders
auf die bewährten gefährdeten menschen
aber ich werde voller überzeugung für
diesen kompromiss weil dieser weg einen
entscheidenden beitrag leisten kann das
infektionsgeschehen zu verringern und
jetzt schaue ich insbesondere richtung
d.red der cdu-fraktion warum weil dieser
kompromiss genau das beinhaltet was sie
fordern das hat frau pieper sehr genau
ausgeführt wird und deshalb bitte ich
sie inständig denken sie an kinder wie
lehrer denken sie an die kinder die alle
massive einschränkungen hinnehmen
mussten in den letzten zwei jahren
lassen sie das nicht noch mal zu im
herbst lassen sie bitte für diese
familien ihre partei spielchen beiseite
lassen sie uns zum wohle der menschen in
diesem land abstimmen ich bitte sie
inständig stimmen sie diesen kopf guten
kompromiss zu helfen sie das
infektionsgeschehen zu reduzieren und
geben sie den menschen die seit zwei
jahren isoliert sind endlich ihre
freiheit zurück vielen dank
nina star hat hier noch mal die gruppe
angesprochen die ohnehin so ein bisschen
in die röhre schaut denn zb das masken
tragen wird ja nicht mehr notwendig
werden und alle möglichen dinge werden
abgebaut der gleiche gesetzgeber will im
herbst eine impfpflicht und
das wiederum
will auch dieter janitschek der
zunächste von den bündnisgrünen für den
ulmern vorschlag war und jetzt dem
kompromiss beigetreten ist impfen ab 60
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin der
heutige tag könnte eine sternstunde des
deutschen bundestages werden denn wir
ernst nehmen was wir uns versprochen
haben dass diese wesentliche
entscheidung heute über die einführung
einer impfpflicht in deutschland eine
gewissen
jedes und jeder einzelnen ist wir frei
abgewählte die frei gewählte abgeordnete
tragen heute die verantwortung und wir
lassen uns dabei nicht leiten von
fraktionszwängen und parteitaktischen
erwägungen
und ja frei herr müller ich glaube ihnen
dass sie sich ernsthaft
auseinandergesetzt haben und ich zolle
ihnen respekt ich zolle auch herrn
kubicki respekt auch all denjenigen die
heute gegen eine impfpflicht stimmt aber
was ich ihnen nicht glaube ist dass ihre
100 97 abgeordnete alle die gleiche
position haben sie sich völlig
unterscheidet von den acht cdu
ministerpräsidenten geben sie die
abstimmung heute frei
nehmen sie ihre verantwortung wahr
diese pandemie hat uns allen viel
abverlangt und auch ich habe mich heute
schwergetan
diesen vorschlag zuzustimmen
doch nach langer intensiver debatte ist
heute der tag zu einer entscheidung zu
kommen oben bestmöglich auf den
kommenden herbst und vorbereitet zu sein
und ich glaube dass dies antrag der
impfung ab 60 deswegen gangbar ist er
eben verhältnismäßig ist er konzentriert
sich auf die hauptbetroffenen
risikogruppen und es ist nun mal so dass
über 90 prozent der intensivpatienten
über 60 sind und es sterben immer noch
so viele die aktuelle im quote reicht
nicht um sicherzustellen dass es nicht
zu einer erneuten schweren belastung
unseres gesundheitssystems kommt
lassen sie mich zum schluss
eine persönliche note sagen ich habe in
den letzten zwei jahren nicht sehr oft
zu dem thema geäußert dass kinder und
jugendliche in der pandemie aus meiner
sicht zu stark eingeschränkt worden sind
ich fand das war falsch wie wir in der
summe vorgegangen waren und auch
deswegen will ich keinen winter mehr
erleben indem die mangelnde impfquote
bei den älteren dafür erhält
weitreichende einschränkungen bei
kindern und jugendlichen zu
rechtfertigen bitte stimmen sie deswegen
für den kompromiss geben sie sich einen
ruck lassen sie uns zusammen arbeiten in
dieser wichtigen frage bilder
[Applaus]
es folgt die kollegin heike behrens für
die gruppe während janácek
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen jetzt gilt es
farbe zu bekennen wer tatsächlich
vorsorgen will wer endlich ein im
frigges das schaffen will ja wer sich
zutraut noch einmal mit einer wichtigen
kraftanstrengung für das impfen zu
werden mit einer engagierten beratungs
kampagne die impfquote auf das niveau zu
heben das uns vor die nächste welle
bringt der sollte heute dem gesetz zur
pandemievorsorge zustimmen
es war richtig die diskussion über eine
allgemeine impfpflicht ausführlich hier
im bundestag aber auch in der gesamten
gesellschaft zu führen auf die fach
expertise aus den verschiedensten
bereichen zu hören und in
veranstaltungen im gespräch oder per
mail mit vielen vielen bürgerinnen und
bürgern zu diskutieren und
fraktionsübergreifend um den richtigen
weg zu bringen
und da bleibt es irritierend und
befremdlich dass ausgerechnet die
christdemokraten sich diesen politischen
prozess der konsensbildung entzogen
haben
die versorger sie haben vorhin gesagt ja
reichen ihnen die hand zur versöhnung
wir haben gar nicht gestritten weil sie
sich der diskussion entzogen haben
sie wollen heute hier aus rein
parteitaktischen kalkül die abstimmung
zum scheitern bringen und das ist nicht
in ordnung denn wer vorsorgen will der
muss vorsorge und nicht das dann
reagieren wenn die infektionswelle in
sicht ist und darum verabschieden sie
sich endlich von ihrer mogelpackung
mit dem vorliegenden gesetzentwurf haben
wir brücken gebaut eine brücke zwischen
zwei gesetzentwürfen eine brücke
zwischen vielen abgeordneten die
gesellschaftliche verantwortung
übernehmen wollen die vorsorge treffen
wollen um uns vor einem dritten pandemie
herbst zu schützen ob wir ihn alle
erlauben sie eine zwischenfrage aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion ja
vielen dank frau kollegin während da sie
mich ja direkt angesprochen haben wollte
ich sieben runden nur fragen sie
erwecken ja hier wieder den eindruck als
seien wenig gesprächsbereit gewesen und
ich möchte diesen eindruck hier auch
nicht so stehen lassen da sie ja in den
gesprächen beziehungsweise in den
signalen man könnte ja noch mal drüber
sprechen nachdem wir das ja seit ende
letzten jahres angeboten haben wo das
immer belächelt worden ist dann kam
unsere kompromissvorschlag dann ist
dieser auch mehr oder weniger belächelt
wurden und als sie jetzt auf den letzten
metern mitbekommen haben dass sie keine
mehrheit für diese allgemeine
impfpflicht bekommen diese danach
geschenke in anführungsstrichen zu
machen und zu sagen na ja wir könnten ja
übernimmt register mal reden das kommt
dann irgendwann das ist ja aus ihrer
sicht vielleicht ein gesprächsangebot
wir haben immer darauf hingewiesen dass
wir uns mal grundsätzlich zusammensetzen
müssten und dieser vorschlag den wir
gemacht haben der ist ja selbst von
vielen kolleginnen kollegen von ihnen
gutgeheissen wurden die sache uns ja
selbst das ist der gangbarer weg weil
sie ja selbst sich nicht so sicher sind
also von 18 auf 15 auf 60 sie haben
anfang der woche ein kompromiss
verkündet mit der gruppe 50 die post
hätten gesagt haben das ist mit denen
gar nicht abgesprochen gewesen mit uns
auch nicht also ich will nur deshalb
noch einmal darauf hinweisen dass auch
ihr argument was nicht immer bringen
also der im vorsorge mich mechanismus
den wir als union vorgeschlagen haben
sei zu spät ich will nur darauf
hinweisen es geht darum dass wir
reagieren können und der im focus sorge
mechanismus heißt die haben momentan die
impfzentren müssen wieder in stand by
gehalten wir können millionen von
menschen haben in der hochphase bewiesen
innerhalb von tagen impfen und das hat
meine frage sind sie mit mir nicht auch
der meinung dass es darum geht vorsorge
zu treffen was wir sehr schnell tun
können mit unserem vorsorge mechanismus
anstatt jetzt pauschal in grundrechte
einzugreifen in dem wissen dass das
überhaupt für den herbst nichts bringen
würde
also zum einen will ich einfach mit
dieser mehr noch mal aufräumen dass sie
gesprächsbereit gewesen wären es ist der
versuch unternommen worden auf ganz
unterschiedlichen ebenen zwischen den
fraktionen zwischen abgeordneten
kolleginnen und kollegen mit ihnen ganz
konstruktiv in den dialog zu kommen und
dieses war nicht möglich weil sie seit
monaten ausschließlich auf ihren antrag
verweisen da ja nicht mal ein
gesetzentwurf sie sind ja nicht mehr als
größte oppositionsfraktion in der lage
einen abendlichen gesetzentwurf für das
kurzen legen lassen uns hier
sie präsentieren wollen
und sie haben es ist völliger unsinn er
frei nein das ist völliger unsinn was
sie da sagen
der andere punkt ist sie haben selbst
eben in ihrem beitrag noch einmal gesagt
sie wollen reagieren ja reagieren seit
zwei jahren
situationsangepasst und versuchen die
infektionswellen so klein wie möglich zu
halten
reaktion alleine reicht nicht sondern
echte vorsorge ist gefragt und genau
dafür
und genau darf heute ein gesetzentwurf
zur abstimmung der eingestuftes vorgehen
vorsieht und der vor allem für zwei
zentrale punkte ihres antrages mit
aufnimmt nämlich dass er wirklich in
schritten diese umsetzung macht dass er
die zielgruppe der 60-jährigen die
besonders gefährdet sind durch eine
infektion hier adressiert und vor allem
und da habe ich den eindruck sie haben
den gesetzentwurf nicht mal gelesen es
ist ein ganz klarer auftrag tatsächlich
das imwf register jetzt auf den weg zu
bringen das müssten sie eigentlich heute
unterstützt
und darum
sie alle ihre kolleginnen und kollegen
heute noch einmal einen für diesen
kompromiss zustimmen denn es ist nicht
mehr zu akzeptieren dass so viele
menschen an corona sterben es darf nicht
sein dass wir noch einmal in einen lock
down müssen und es darf nicht mehr sein
dass tumorpatienten auf operationen
warten müssen dass patienten wegen
personalausfall durch bewohner nicht
aufgenommen werden
dass wir alle und unsere familien vor
allem unsere familien mit kindern oder
auch alte menschen darunter leiden und
auch und das will ich auch noch mal die
cdu/csu sagen und auf unserer wirtschaft
sind die pandemie last nicht weiter
zuzumuten
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich
appelliere noch einmal an sie verlassen
sie ihre parteipolitische zwickmühle
sorgen sie jetzt mit uns vor stimmen sie
für unseren gesetzentwurf vielen dank
allerdings hat hier noch mal um die
stimmen der cdu geworden und darum wird
es am schluss gehen einen antrag braucht
hier eine einfache mehrheit also mehr ja
als nein stimmen und die impfpflicht ab
60 kommt momentan so rauter bord auf 280
stimmen das bedeutet es könnten
wesentlich mehr nein- stimmen seien
deswegen hofft diese antragssteller
hoffen auf stimmen der union tisch
definiert
wir entscheiden heute darüber ob er
endlich raus kommen aus dieser
dauerschleife von lock down und
lockerungen das hat unser land genug
erlebt die leute haben die schnauze voll
davon und heute fällt hier die
entscheidung ob wir es schaffen da
rauszukommen
und wie entscheidet der deutsche
bundestag der deutsche bundestag
entscheidet dadurch dass er gesetze
beschließt
meistens
gesetze die ihm die bundesregierung
vorschlägt
und manche finden das gut dass die
bundesregierung hier keinen vorschlag
gemacht habt andere fitness blöd aber es
ist so wie es ist und unsere verfassung
sieht nicht vor dass man nur gesetze
beschliessen kann wenn die
bundesregierung einen vorschlag machen
sondern
jede fraktion jede gruppe kann
vorschläge für gesetze machen und das
haben wir gemacht wir haben diskutiert
mit kollegen der linken mit kollegen der
fdp mit kollegen der grünen und der spd
wir waren gesprächsbereit haben jetzt
erörtern und was nicht von ihnen vor
kein gesetz eine besinnung auf satz
nicht vor das liebherr abgeordneten
erlauben sie eine zwischenfrage aus der
afg fraktion ein und die haben uns
angeschaut ist ja nicht gesagt dass das
uninteressant ist da stehen interessante
punkte drin wir haben wir ein gearbeitet
das ist deutlich gemacht worden dass es
da kommt weil dies gefordert und wir es
eingearbeitet haben weil wir die arbeit
gemacht haben daraus eine gesetzliche
formulierung zu machen wir haben das
gemacht
wir wollen die besten ideen zusammen
führt in diesem gesetz weil wir die
besten ideen brauchen um die pandemie zu
bekämpfen und das ist dass herr frei was
sie mit allen mitteln bekämpfen wollen
ich finde das traurig und dass sie
diesen brief schreiben müssen zeigt ja
auch was für ein druck in ihrer fraktion
ist ich möchte dass wir heute
entscheiden ein anderer herbst ein
anderer winter und ein weg raus aus der
pandemie vielen dank
und jetzt meine damen und herren kommt
der letzte redner wie praktisch wenn sie
bei phoenix von anfang an dabei waren
die kennen sich schon das ist nämlich
die akquise der stellvertretende der
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
der spd der auch für den antrag ab 60
ist sie wollen heute entscheiden
dass sich jemand impfen lassen muss und
dafür das zeigen die statistiken auch
vom paul-ehrlich-institut
unter umständen
stirbt
und es gibt einen
bundesverfassungsgerichts urteil
wo ist sie werden sich wahrscheinlich
daran erinnern an das
luftsicherheitsgesetz
da hat das bundesverfassungsgerichts
folgendes gesagt und zwar am 15 februar
artikel 1 ich lese ich zitiere mit ihrer
genehmigung artikel 1 absatz 1
grundgesetz schützt den einzelnen
menschen nicht nur vor erniedrigung
brandmarkung verfolgung ächtung und
ähnlichen handlungen durch dritte oder
durch den staat selbst ausgehend von der
vorstellung des grundgesetz gebers dass
es zum wesen des menschen gehört in
freiheit sich selbst bestimmen und sich
frei entfalten und das der einzige
verlangen kann in der gemeinschaft
grundsätzlich als gleichberechtigtes
glied mit eigenwert anerkannt zu werden
schließt die verpflichtung zur achtung
zum schutz der mensch würde vielmehr
generell aus den menschen zum bloßen
objekt des staates zu machen schlechthin
verboten ist damit jede behandlung des
menschen durch die öffentliche gewalt
die dessen subjekt qualität seinen
status als rechts vom bag grundsätzlich
infrage gestellt indem sie die achtung
des wertes vermissen lässt der jedem
menschen um seiner selbst willen kraft
seiner person science zukommt jemanden
per gesetz zu ermächtigen leben
gegeneinander aufzuwiegen also menschen
leben zu opfern um andere menschenleben
zu schützen schließt des
bundesverfassungsgerichts somit aus
dieses gesetz was sie hier beschließen
wollen ist also nicht nur im höchsten
maße menschenfeindlich sondern
offensichtlich auch verfassungswidrig
der abgeordnete wollen sie antworten
kollege ihre
verdrehungen falschbehauptungen
werden durch wiederholung nicht besser
hätten knapp und ich war leben schon
etwas zu schlendern aber jetzt wird wohl
wirklich devise als letzter redner hier
nochmal den antrag unterstützen in
pflicht wie 60 der bundeskanzler will es
der gesundheitsminister will es und will
es auch die mehrheit hier im hohen hause
wir werden das spätestens in zwei
stunden ist kolleginnen und kollegen wir
treffen einer langen intensiven debatte
jetzt hier und heute im deutschen
bundestag die entscheidung darüber ob
diese pandemie für uns im kommenden
herbst und winter beherrschbar ist ob
wir wenn wir heute eine negative
entscheidung treffen wieder darüber
nachdenken müssen wieder freiheits
einschränkungen auch den weg zu bringen
wie der schließung in der gastronomie
auf den weg zu bringen wie der
einschränkung für kinder und jugendliche
auf den weg zu bringen oder ob wir hier
die verantwortungsvolle entscheidung
heute treffen vorzusorgen richtig
vorzusorgen dass die pandemie für uns
beherrschbar ist und das ist die
entscheidung die jetzt gleich hier und
heute hier getroffen werden
und als größte gruppe haben wir uns
dafür entschieden verantwortung zu
übernehmen wir haben erkannt dass die
mehrheit für eine allgemeine impfpflicht
ab 18 ich da ist wir haben aber erkannt
dass wenn wir die anträge und
gesetzentwürfe zusammenlegen ist
eigentlich eine mehrheit für eine
impfpflicht im deutschen bundestag gibt
diese verantwortung haben wir angenommen
wir haben gespräche angeboten und will
ich ausdrücklich sagen ich bin der
gruppe ullmann dankbar dass wir zusammen
gefunden haben gemeinsam uns oft einen
gesetzentwurf verständigt der genau dazu
führen soll die pandemie beherrscht wird
zu machen und da haben wir als stärkste
gruppe gemeinsam verantwortung
übernommen das auch gut so gewesen und
ich würde es auch ausdrücklich
formulieren ja wir haben auch immer
wieder mit kolleginnen und kollegen der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion
gesprochen lieber sepp müller wir haben
auch in der vergangenen woche am
mittwoch gemeinsam zusammen gesessen
auch mit dem kollegen stefan müller und
haben in gesprächen ausgelotet ob es
möglich ist zusammenzukommen und ich
muss sagen dass die csu das sei mir
gestattet da sehr viel konstruktiver in
dieser runde gewesen ist uns sehr viel
näher sich dem kompromiss an nähern
konnte als es die union gewesen ist und
wir haben auch sehr deutlich gemacht
dass aus unserer sicht es möglich ist
zusammenzufinden aber gespräche sind
etwas anderes als konkrete verhandlungen
ich muss das auch sehr deutlich sagen
nachdem friedrich merz am samstagmorgen
einen tweet abgesetzt hat waren die
gesprächskanäle ruhig und es hat sich
keiner mehr gemeldet und es hat sich
keiner mehr zu ernsthaften verhandlungen
von ihrer seite bereit erklärt und das
bedauere ich sehr und wird der
verantwortung nicht gerecht und das muss
ich auch sehr deutlich sagen
jeder friedrich merz gesagt dass auch
sehr deutlich im sauerland sagen wir
beide ja dass franz müntefering im
zweifel recht opposition ist mist aber
opposition entbindet nicht von
staatspolitischer verantwortung und ich
sage das auch sehr gold
ich sage das sehr deutsch
man kann nicht hier im deutschen
bundestag heute sagen ich verweigere
mich staatspolitischer verantwortung
aber morgen stehe ich für gespräche
wieder bereit das ist unverantwortlich
und das ist nicht seriös vielen dank
der hatte wie sie noch mal runter
gebracht die ganz großen geschütze
ausgepackt es geht auf beiden seiten und
taktisches geplänkel und es gibt
natürlich um sachfragen und letzte
sollten auch überwiegen denn es geht
hier um eine ernsthafte krankheit das
sollte man zumindest meinen aber so ist
es natürlich nicht das ist hier das
ganze eine hochpolitische angelegenheit
natürlich
und
jetzt kann friedrich merz fraktionschef
noch einmal persönlich etwas sagen wenn
er denn will ich weiß gar nicht ob er
will
asus hat übrigens übernommen und
tatsächlich friedrich merz ist
aufgestanden denn team
persönlich sehr häufig angesprochen
worden in der debatte und auch noch
einmal im namen der unions fraktion
würde gerne
drei bemerkungen machen die erste ist es
handelt sich hier jedenfalls nach der
überzeugung der mehrheit unserer
bundestagsfraktion
nicht um eine gewissensentscheidung
es kann sein es kann sein dass es nicht
bei einzelnen abgeordneten um eine
gewissensentscheidung handelt aber dann
nicht aus weder der bundeskanzler noch
ein anderer redner hier im deutschen
bundestag fest dann entscheidet das
jeder abgeordnete für sich ganz allein
bis auf sehr wenige ausnahmen bis auf
sehr wenige ausnahmen sind wir in
unserer bundestagsfraktion einer meinung
was dieses thema impfpflicht betrifft
und deswegen gibt es von uns anders als
von allen anderen bundestagsfraktionen
hier einen gemeinsamen antrag die zweite
datum ist
wir sind hier von vielen rednern und ich
persönlich sehr hart kritisiert worden
für unsere haltung
naja ich wir akzeptieren das ist völlig
in ordnung aber dadurch doch einmal mir
den hinweis erlauben dass die tatsache
dass sie sich überhaupt so intensiv mit
uns beschäftigen müssen ihre ursache
allein darin hat dass diese fraktion
hier
überhaupt keine zustimmung zu einer
impfpflicht im deutschen bundestag
erwägt überhaupt keine
und deswegen ist meine dritte bemerkung
deswegen ist meine dritte bemerkung wenn
sie es wirklich ernst meinen mit einem
kompromiss dann manipulieren sie nicht
die reihenfolge der abstimmungen in der
wir jetzt vorgehen
wenn das ist der entscheidende
das ist der entscheidende test ob sie es
ernst meinen mit einem kompromiss der
weitergehende antrag ist ihre unser
antrag ist ein weniger weit gehende
antrag und diesen antrag können wir dann
gemeinsam beschließen und auf den weg
bringen mit einem gesetz im deutschen
bundestag aber nicht so wie sie es
machen um offensichtlich hier davon
abzulenken dass sie in ihrer eigenen
regierung keine mehrheit haben für das
was auf dieser fraktion kommt
märz auch er hat das wiederum schloss
vorhin schon mal gehört habe dass die
union der ein ziel beschlossener antrag
seiner fraktion vorlegt das ist
ungerecht die afg hat ebenfalls einen
antrag gestellt bis zunächst die
reihenfolge der abstimmung festzulegen
es liegt ein vorschlag der fraktion der
cdu csu vor die abstimmung in folgender
reihenfolge vorzunehmen gesetzentwurf
berends janitschek und andere antrag cdu
csu antrag von bp und andere antrag afd
die gruppe behrens janitschek und andere
hingegen beantragt die abstimmung in der
reihenfolge vorzunehmen antrag afd
antrag kubicki und andere antrag cdu/csu
gesetzentwurf behrens janitschek
bevor wir darüber abstimmen wird nun
erst mal das wort zur geschäftsordnung
gewünscht und das wort hat für die
cdu/csu thorsten frei
der parlamentarische geschäftsführer
thorsten frei wird jetzt hierzu der
reihenfolge der abstimmung der anträge
reden
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
wir haben es jetzt in den letzten
minuten und auch in den letzten
zweieinhalb stunden gehört wo der hase
im pfeffer liegt sie haben keine eigene
parlamentarische mehrheit deswegen
flüchten sie sich in die gruppenanträge
das ist der einzige grund und am ende
dieser debatte ist es so dass sie
versuchen mit einer nicht angemessenen
reihenfolge der abstimmungen des
verfahrens zu torpedieren das
akzeptieren wir nicht das ist ein
deutlicher beweis dafür dass sie der
überzeugungskraft ihrer eigenen vorlagen
misstrauen das ist rechtsmissbräuchlich
und deswegen lehnen wir das abkommen
geht es im kern
worum geht es im kern
wir haben eine lange parlamentarische
tradition dass immer zunächst über den
weitestgehenden antrag abgestimmt wird
so machen dass tausende von gemeinderäte
bei uns in deutschland zu machen dass 16
länderparlamente der bundesrat macht es
so der hat es sogar in seiner
geschäftsordnung im paragrafen 30 absatz
2 normiert und so macht es der deutsche
bundestag seit jahrzehnten
es gibt praktisch keine ausnahmen davon
wenn ich eine finden würde dann wäre es
vielleicht im jahr 2009 als es um die
gesetzlichen regelungen für die
patientenverfügung gehen und dort ging
es darum dass man im grunde genommen
nicht exakt sagen konnte welches denn
der weitergehende antrag ist hier ist es
aber vollkommen klar fluchtpunkt ist die
realität der gesetzlichen status quo und
wer am weitesten von gesetzlichen status
quo abweicht der hat den weitestgehenden
antrag und über den muss als erstes
abgestimmt werden
zulegen diese bundesregierung ist der
auffassung dass wir keine maske pflicht
mehr brauchen diese bundesregierung war
wenigstens für einige stunden der
auffassung dass wir keine quarantäne für
infizierte wir brauchen diese
bundesregierung und diese diese
fraktionen hier im parlament wollen uns
aber weiß sagen dass eine impfpflicht
nicht der weitestgehend der antrag ist
und jedenfalls eine klare eingriffe in
die grundrechte das nimmt ihnen doch
kein mensch im land ab es ist einfach
nicht schlüssig und deswegen bitte ich
sie hier richtig abzustimmen ich will
auf eines hinweisen die regeln betreffen
aber dazu geschäftsjahr nicht zu den
inhalten das will ich gerne machen frau
präsidentin die güte der
parlamentarischen demokratie zeigt sich
nicht darin dass am ende die mehrheit
entscheidet das ist selbstverständlich
sie zeigt sich darin dass die mehrheit
auch schranken akzeptiert schranken die
auch her gebrachtes recht hier im
parlament sind und darauf müssen sich
abgeordnete auch verlassen können und
darum geht es tauschen sie nicht aus
billigem machtpolitischem kalkül
politische kultur in diesem haus ein und
ein letztlich will ich sagen hat
die hessischen wälder zum schnuppern wir
haben bei dieser frage eine starke
polarisierung hier bei uns im land es
geht auch darum das zu überwinden und
mit der von ihnen vorgeschlagenen
abstimmungs reihenfolge die letztlich
nur zum ziel hat den eigenen antrag zum
erfolg zu bringen
dem würden auch ein makel an heften
sollten sie sollte es ihnen gelingen
hier eine mehrheit zu gewinnen das wird
die akzeptanz nicht hilfreich wenn die
sicherheit nicht fördern und es wird
nicht dazu führen dass gräben in unserem
land zugeschüttet werden deswegen bitte
ich um zustimmung für unseren antrag
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das ist
eine wichtige debatte die müssen wir
auch ordentlich führen aber man sollte
bei einer geschäftsordnungsdebatte nicht
erst in der überziehung der zeit dann
auch auf die geschäftsordnung eingehen
da möchte ich noch mal eindringlich
darauf plädieren jetzt erhält das wort
hat
katja mast die parlamentarische
geschäftsführerin der spd
bundestagsfraktion normalerweise werden
solche abstimmungsverfahren vorher zum
beispiel dem ältestenrat geregelt aber
man konnte sich nicht einigen
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
kolleginnen und kollegen meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren lieber
thorsten frei wer mit anderen auch mit
dem finger zeigt da zeigen immer vier
zurück das sollte man sich bewusst
machen wenn man solche reden hält um was
geht es hier eigentlich
es geht hier um eine
abstimmungs reihenfolge es geht hier
darum dass die geschäftsordnung des
deutschen bundestags sich nicht zu einer
abstimmungs reihenfolge im deutschen
bundestag äußert und nichts fest lebt
und es geht darum dass die verwaltung
des deutschen bundestags allen
fraktionen anheim gestellt hat zwei
unterschiedliche wege abzustimmen
nämlich den weg die gesetzentwürfe
zuerst und dann die anträge nach
reichweite oder umgekehrt die anträge
und dann die gesetzentwürfe nach
reichweite und das ist das worum es geht
es geht nicht um mehr und nicht weniger
bei dieser entscheidung und es ist
völlig normal dass in der demokratie
wenn es zwei verschiedene wege gibt man
abstimmt und die mehrheit am ende
entscheidet das ist das normalste von
der welt und 2009 bei der
patientenverfügung hat mein kollege ja
gerade gesagt gab es auch schon mal also
es ist nicht so dass es nicht
historische vorbilder auch gäbe herr
merz sie dürften sich noch keiner sie
waren damals gerade noch abgeordneter
herr frey war noch kein abgeordneter
dollar aber was sie aufhören ist einfach
großes tamtam und sie haben die worte
noch mal benutzt manipulation tricks
machtkalkül das sind die finger die auch
sie zeigen an dieser stelle dass es
rechtlich machen technokratie parlament
und das erweist das auf entschiedenste
zurück wie kann man jetzt diese anträge
wie kann man diese anträge abstimmen
könnt sie anhand der anzahl der
unterschriften abstimmen in der
reihenfolge dann würden wir kubicki
zuerst aufstehe dann unionen dann den
gesetzentwurf abstimmen wir können
abstimmen nach der reihenfolge was
schafft eigentlich für die bürgerinnen
und bürger klarheit weil die bürgerinnen
und bürger die uns heute zu hören die
wollen doch dass wir eine entscheidung
treffen in diesem aus und sie wissen
woran sie sind eigentlich
nicht
ständig war nur ein gesetz gibt diese
sicherheit am ende des tages es geht um
klarheit klarheit die die bürgerinnen
und bürger verdient haben die zwei jahre
mit uns durch diese pandemie gegangen
sind und dieser stimmzettel sieht ganz
klar vor den wir haben die reihenfolge
der tam tam partei
cdu csu dass die erste reihenfolge man
kann die reihenfolge zwei werden dass es
in der geschäftsordnung möglich und alle
alle alle die meine argumente hier nicht
überzeugt haben ich weiß es gibt welche
davon im deutschen bundestag sie können
wenn sie nicht jetzt cdu steigbügel haid
was sein wollen für dieses spektakel
dessen ja veranstalten sich auch in teil
des sports
stimmen sie zur reihenfolge zwei weil
diese abstimmung
sagen sie leben ein spektakel das ist
der oberste gesetzgeber den wir hier
lauschen und man muss sich schon wundern
solche dinge kann man wirklich ältesten
abklären aber darum geht es nicht es
geht hier um politische zielsetzung und
deswegen wird auch weiter debattiert
obwohl es eigentlich alles gesagt ist
irene mihalic jetzt die parlamentarische
geschäftsführerin der bündnisgrünen
vielleicht beruhigen wir uns jetzt alle
erst mal wieder
die gemüter sind erhitzt sehr geehrte
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegen ich finde auch jetzt diese
geschäftsordnungsdebatte und auch die
inhaltliche debatte zeigt uns allen ja
sehr sehr deutlich für emotionalisiert
diese angelegenheit hier im deutschen
bundestag behandelt wird und ist es auch
wichtig dass wir hier wirklich eine
verantwortungsbewusste entscheidung
treffen denn der situation in der wir
uns in der pandemie bekämpfung und in
der wir uns hier mit unserem land
befinden und in dieser situation herr
freiherr märz haben sie sich dafür
entschieden mit uns über die abstimmungs
reihenfolge diskutieren zu wollen und
uns und uns tricksereien und rechts
missbräuchliches handeln vorzuwerfen
dabei sind sie es doch dabei sind sie es
doch die mit allen mitteln versuchen zu
verhindern dass ihre abgeordneten hier
eine entscheidung treffen die sie nun
nach ihrem gewissen
und die wirklich angemessen wäre in der
sache sie versuchen wir mit allen
mitteln zu verhindern dass ihre
abgeordneten hier eine
verantwortungsbewusste entscheidung
treffen indem sie hier so eine
geschäftsordnungsdebatte vom zaun
brechen aber nicht
erfreut nicht wie sind es die ihre
abgeordneten daran hindern hier eine
entscheidung in der sache
verantwortungsbewusst zu treffen sondern
sie sind ist sie setzen ihre leute unter
druck sie sagen sie sollen einem impuls
widerstehen falls ihr antrag keine
mehrheit bekommt anderen vorlagen
zuzustimmen meine damen und herren was
ist das für ein demokratieverständnis
dass es um parlamentarisch und das ist
hat auch nichts mit
verantwortungsbewusster pandemie politik
zu tun und auf ihren wunsch ihr
diskutieren wir jetzt über die
abstimmungs reihenfolge um eine kollegin
katja mast hat ihnen gerade noch einmal
erklärt welche varianten hier zur
abstimmung stehen und auch wie diese
habe abstimmungsvarianten auf den
stimmzettel gelangt sind es handelt sich
dabei um vorschläge die die
bundestagsverwaltung uns unterbreitet
hat die alle fraktionen bekommen
haben die auch die antrags initiativen
die gruppen bekommen haben und zwischen
denen man jetzt entscheiden kann das ist
demokratisch das ist transparent das
sind sachgerecht sie empfehlen ihrer
fraktion die erste variante wir
empfehlen unserer fraktion für
abstimmungsvarianten zwei zustimmen uns
in dieser situation tricksereien
vorzuwerfen ist absurd meinte horner
und lassen sie mich zum schluss noch
sagen und lassen sie mich zum schluss
noch sagen wenn wir jetzt endlich per
stimmzettel verfahren über die
abstimmungs reihenfolge entschieden
haben dann geht es hier wirklich um was
dann geht es hier wirklich darum eine
sachgerechte entscheidung mit blick auf
den weiteren verlauf unserer pandemie zu
treffen und lassen sie mich diese
bemerkung noch machen herr frey artikel
38 des grundgesetzes gilt auch für die
fraktionen der cdu/csu an ganz herzlich
[Applaus]
für die fdp fraktion erhält nun das wort
johannes vogel
tja und jetzt werden alle fraktionen
ihre parlamentarische geschäftsführer
sprechen dass in johannesburg steht frau
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wir haben jetzt hier eben vom
eigentlich von mir sehr geschätzten
kollegen thorsten frei indem im plenum
des deutschen bundestag wieder etwas
erlebt was wir die letzten tage schon
erleben dürften da haben sie ganz heftig
in die rhetorische trickkiste gegriffen
und parlamentarisch eine manipulation
sie haben sich sogar eben dazu
verstiegen es sei rechtsmissbräuchlich
dass hier über die abstimmungs
reihenfolge abgestimmt wird lieber
kollege frei lieber kollege freiheit das
beschädigt die politische kultur hier
bei uns im parlament man riecht ganz ja
es ist eben in der sache nicht so
eindeutig wie war es den damals bei den
gruppen antragsverfahren oder das
bonn-berlin-gesetz wie ist es hier der
afg antrag übrigens der ändert auch ganz
eindeutig die rechtslage in deutschland
um die argument mal als absurdum zu
führen also die abstimmungs reihenfolge
ist einfach nicht so ganz eindeutig und
wir haben im deutschen bundestag eine
ganz klare regelung bei zahllosen
gruppen verfahren nämlich wenn es kein
einvernehmen über die abstimmungs
reihenfolge gibt dann wird über die
abstimmungs reihenfolge abgestimmt so
einfach herr kollege zeit so einfach ist
es
und es wurde ja schon gesagt 2009 hatten
wir genau das zur patientenverfügung da
war ihr fraktionsvorsitzender im
deutschen bundestag da gab es keine
einigkeit danach wurde über die
abstimmungs reihenfolge abgestimmt
irgendein protest von friedrich merz
irgendein theater wie wir sie heute
erleben irgendein proteste union ist im
protokoll nicht vermerkt sie vögeln im
klassenzimmer rummachen aber nicht mal
die hausaufgaben liebe kolleginnen
kollegen von der union und das ist der
sache unangemessen schlicht ohne
angemessen
ich versteh schon worum es ihm geht sie
wollen gerne dass von den anträgen die
sich irgendwie etwas mehr in richtung
impfpflicht vorstellen können ihre als
letztes abgestimmt wird weil sie hoffen
dass diejenigen die jugend was machen
wollen dann sich hinter ihrem antrag
sammeln das ist okay das dürfen sie so
wollen ich sage ihnen aber wie meine
persönliche meinung ist ich glaube bei
einer grundrechtssensiblen frage wie bei
einer impfpflicht da geht es nicht darum
irgend was zu beschließen sondern da
muss jede als eine vorlage eine aktive
mehrheit der kolleginnen und kollegen
hier im deutschen bundestag bekommen und
ich sag ihnen auch noch was ich
persönlich
stimme deshalb gleich ver abstimmungs
reihenfolge 2 weil die genau das
sicherstellt und dann gibt es entweder
für eines der konzepte hier eine
mehrheit oder es gibt sie eben nicht was
auch ein legitimes ergebnis dieser
debatte wer liebe kolleginnen kollegen
gehen gibt es nur darum dass sie
irgendwie sich mit ihrem antrag
durchsetzen und das ist schäbig liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
beschädigt und leider treibt sich dass 1
mein letzter gedanke in ihrem gesamten
umgang mit diesen gruppen
antragsverfahren von anfang an und bis
zur letzten minute haben sie das gruppen
antragsverfahren torpediert das ist eine
der eines der verfahren die unserem
parlamentarismus mit ausmachen bei
medizin ethischen fragen da gab es oft
sternstunden des parlaments und sie
machen gerade noch mehr schreiben an
ihre fraktionskollegen sie machen aus
einer medizin ethischen frage eine
parteipolitische in meiner fraktion gibt
es das nicht liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen von der union und deshalb
kommen sie bitte zum schluss
lage ganz einfach es gab keine einigkeit
über die abstimmungs reihenfolge wir
stimmen ab über die abstimmungs
reihenfolge so machen wir das in unserer
demokratie wir nennen das
parlamentarismus und danach entscheiden
wir klug in der sache vielen dank
das wort erhält der abgeordnete martin
sichert für die afg fraktion
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
die geschäftsordnung und die
parlamentarischen gepflogenheiten sind
grundlagen der demokratie und sie sorgen
dafür dass gesetze nicht schon an
formalen gründen scheitert hier hat man
den eindruck dass selbst die
antragsteller eine impfpflicht diese
nicht wollen denn sie stoßen das tor
weit auf für eine klage vor dem
verfassungsgericht sowohl durch das
vorgehen heute als auch durch das
prozedere gestern im ausschuss dass der
kompromiss dämmpflicht ab 18 und empfing
ab 15 aber 50 die impfpflicht ab 60 sein
soll das ist wirklich bizarr viel
bizarrer aber noch ist das im
gesundheitsausschuss gestern früh nicht
mal zehn minuten nachdem er schriftlich
vorgelegt wurde über einen 25 seitigen
gesetzentwurf
abgestimmt wurde mittags als der
tagesordnungspunkt zu ängstlich bereits
drei stunden beendet war hieß es
plötzlich dass zwei stunden später ein
weiterer änderungsantrag vom
gesundheitsministerium beschlossen
werden müsste dieser änderungsantrag
wäre notwendig weil der in der früh
beschlossene zu viele rechtliche mängel
hat er mit zu heißer nadel ist das ja
alles gestrickt
so bekamen wir dann zum bekamen wir dann
im gesundheitsausschuss um 13 uhr 54 per
mail und um 14 uhr fünf schriftlich
einen nun 31 seitigen gesetzentwurf
vorgelegt trotz unseres protestes wurde
darüber binnen nicht mal zehn minuten
abgestimmt und um 14 uhr 15 war die
sitzung bereits beendet das meine damen
und herren ist kein parlamentarismus das
ist eine farce
kein mensch kann 31 seiten voller
gesetzesänderungen binnen so kurzer zeit
in all ihren auswirkungen erfassen sie
haben mit der mehrheit der
ampelkoalition mal eben den
parlamentarismus ausgeben und wollen es
jetzt im plenum auch noch machen
sie wollen nicht den weitestgehenden
antrag zuerst beraten von diesem über
jahrzehnte in allen parlamenten parteien
und vereinen gelebten verfahren wollen
sie abweichen weil sie glauben dass das
die einzige möglichkeit ist wie sie eine
irgendwie geartete impfpflicht
durchbekommen dabei ist jetzt viel ein
weiterer schlag gegen die demokratie
denn jeder einzelne hier im bundestag
vertretene partei hatte im wahlkampf
versprochen dass es keine impfpflicht
geben wird hören sie auf die demokratie
und den parlamentarismus zu beschädigen
[Applaus]
gerade aufgrund der massiven
grundrechtseingriff um die es hier geht
und der hohen bedeutung ist es wichtig
dass die geschäftsordnung und die
parlamentarischen gepflogenheiten
eingehalten werden daher lassen sie uns
wie immer den weitestgehenden antrag
nämlich die impfpflicht zuerst abstimmen
zum schluss noch 1 dass der
bundeskanzler in dieser zeit die
außenministerin vom nato-treffen
abberuft und der bundesregierung
offensichtlich die einschränkung der
grundrechte in der eigenen bevölkerung
wichtiger ist als der frieden in der
ukraine das ist wirklich entlarvend
schluss mit dieser unwürdigen fast lang
lebe rechtsstaatlichkeit und demokratie
leben wir wieder das verfahren so wie
wir es immer getan haben vielen dank
jetzt fehlt noch ein parlamentarischen
geschäftsführer nämlich der der linken
das wäre jan korte und
es folgt für die fraktion die linke der
abgeordnete jan korte
meine frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren zunächst
kollegin katja macht finde ich schon
relativ bemerkenswert als spd-fraktion
anderen fraktionen zum beispiel meiner
vorzuwerfen
steigbügelhalter der cdu/csu zu sein was
haben sie die letzten 20 jahre
eigentlich gemacht war ja wohl
die rotation gezielt haben
sodann möchte zum zweiten hier anmerken
zu dem verfahren also auch ich halte die
cdu csu fraktion wird nicht in jeder
hinsicht für eine seriöse
oppositionsfraktion aber was ja was aber
nun nicht geht und das ist absolut
deswegen wollen wir gucken wer hat ja
ein demokratie problem dass sie eine
oppositionsfraktion vorwerfen ihre
oppositionsarbeit zu machen das ist nun
wirklich geradezu lächerlich und
protestlager seite sagen das ist ja gut
es aberwitzig diese organisation und zum
dritten möchte ich anmerken die war
johannes vogel also alle machen hier in
diesem hause parteipolitik außer die
parteien der ampel das war gerade zu
sichern dass so etwas zu behaupten
wir haben hier aufhören
möchte zunächst zum verfahren
feststellen wir wären jetzt nicht in
dieser die soll ich sagen etwas
aufgeladenen situationen hier in diesem
hohen hause wenn die letzte
bundesregierung und die jetzige
bundesregierung vernünftige corona
politik gemacht hat und das land ins
chaos durch chancen hätte das ist ja mal
die sachlage was sind müssen wir das
hier diskutieren so und dann will ich
zum zweiten sagt also zu glauben es gibt
keine überlastung des gesundheitssystems
ich weiß nicht was mit ihnen los ist da
müssen wir mit den pflegerinnen und
pflegern reden und im übrigen hatten wir
die belastung auch schon vor corona um
das auch mal in jeder klar jetzt hier zu
sein nun sind hierbei der
geschäftsordnung ich ganz für meine
fraktion die linke sagen dass wir uns
also anträge angucken und grundsätzlich
immer nachfragen entscheiden wieso und
hier verhalten werden ja dass so das ist
ja auch seriös baku was da drinsteht was
der vorschlag ist und hat gucken wir was
am sinnvollsten nach unserer meinung ist
und das unterscheidet uns ja auch zu
ihrer corona politik lieber kollege laut
aber man kann ein guter arzt sein aber
das schafft da nicht das war ein guter
unter dem minister ist deswegen gucken
wir uns das hier an und 1 wissen sie
ganz genau und deswegen ständig sollten
wir hier auch sie von der ampel mal
ehrlich sein ganz ehrlich sein es ist
nötig dass erfand in jedem ortsverein
auch der sozialdemokratischen partei
meiner partei bei aller parteien dass in
jedem ortsverein der weitestgehende
antrag zunächst abgestimmt das ist die
übliche praxis
ist das irgendwie anders geht tun sie
doch nicht einfach so das ist die
übliche praxis und wenn man das jetzt
mal vielleicht übersetzt für die
bürgerinnen und bürger die uns hier zu
hören kann ich doch einfach mal
feststellen und ich bin ein großer
anhänger des impfens halt dass wir einen
großen menschheits fortschritt aber das
ist meine persönliche meinung darüber
kann man streiten aber ich kann doch mal
feststellen ganz alt war das ein
eingriff am körper eines bürgers doch
wohl tendenziell ein weiterer gegner
beschluss des bundestages ist als wenn
es das nicht gibt das ist doch wohl ganz
offensichtlich und deswegen fasse ich zu
sammeln deswegen hatte ich zu sammeln
nur falls sie keine mehrheit als ampel
haben ist meine fraktion nicht bereit
auf logik und ein parlamentarisches
sauberes verfahren zusätzlich vielen
dank
so kolleginnen und kollegen wir haben
jetzt die geschäftsordnungsdebatte zur
abstimmungs reihenfolge geführt jetzt
müssen wir sie festlegen das soll im
wege des stimmzettel verfahrens mit
stimm ausweis erfolgen auf dem
stimmzettel können sie sich für eine der
beiden abstimmungs reihenfolgen
entscheiden oder sich gegenüber beiden
varianten enthalten angenommen ist der
vorschlag der die meisten stimmen auf
sich vereint ich sehe dass sie mit
diesem verfahren einverstanden sind das
ist so beschlossen damit kommen wir zur
abstimmung über die reihenfolge der
namentlichen abstimmung die
schriftführerin und schriftführer sind
bereits einigen plätzen an den ausgabe
tischen an den uhren an den ausgabe
tischen in der west lobby erhalten sie
nach vorzeigen ihre stimmkarte ihre
stimme ausweises in der farbe rosa einen
rosafarbenen stimmzettel sie haben nur
eine stimme mehr als ein kreuz oder
andere zusätze führen zur ungültigkeit
des stimmzettels
sie haben zur abgabe ihrer stimme nach
eröffnung der abstimmung circa zehn
minuten zeit es ist jetzt 11 53 sie
haben jetzt zehn minuten zeit ich
eröffne die abstimmung
ja meine damen und herren das was wir
hier gerade erleben hat er mit der sache
nichts zu tun und die sache ist wahrlich
ernst genug wie schützen wir uns vor
einer weiteren corona pandemie können
wir jetzt schon festlegen dass es
zwangsimpfungen geben muss damit wir
alle geschützt sind oder können wir das
erst im herbst festlegen oder kann dass
der gesetzgeber grundsätzlich gar nicht
festlegen eigentlich geht es darum in
der sache jetzt geht es hier um die
abstimmungs reihenfolge auch mal was
schönes und zwar haben nun mehrere
geschäftsführer noch mal deutlich
gemacht dass die abstimmungs reihenfolge
festgelegt wurde vom deutschen bundestag
hier entweder in der reihenfolge der
weitestgehende antrag zuerst das wäre
dann der gesetzentwurf der kompromiss
sozusagen im pflicht ab 60 jahren der
zweitjüngste wäre weit gäste wäre dann
im das im vorsorge gesetzt was die union
vorschlägt und jetzt kommt die unlogik
die kein mensch verstehen kann auf dem
zettel steht dann der antrag von herrn
kubicki herr kubicki ist aber am
nächsten mit seinem antrag am jetzigen
status quo der bild zwar keine
impfpflicht er will die bevölkerung
auffordern sich ordentlich impfen zu
lassen aber sonst will er gar nichts
anderes während die afd
die hierauf der reihung dann am schluss
sozusagen am nächsten des status quo
sein soll mit ihrem antrag nicht nur
eine impfpflicht ablehnt sondern auch
die abschaffung des beruf der
berufsbezogenen in pflicht fordert
dieser antrag ist doch wohl weitgehender
als der von herrn kubicki und egal wie
man es dreht und wendet das was die cdu
hier anreihung vorschlägt die
die koalitionsfraktionen schlagen genau
das gegenteil vor mit dem am wenigsten
vom status quo abweichenden antrag
anzufangen um dann am schluss mit dem
mit dem gesetzentwurf dem pflicht ab 60
zu ende sie schlagen nämlich vor mit der
afg anzufangen dann kubicki dann cdu und
dann im pflicht ab 60 ehrlich gesagt das
kann ich nicht nachvollziehen denn auch
hier ist der logische fehler dass am
nächsten am status quo sich befinden am
nächsten am status quo sich befindliche
antrag ist der antrag von wolfgang
kubicki der sagt es bleibt alles so wie
es ist es gibt keine impfpflicht für
jedermann auch für keine
bevölkerung die über 60 ist über 50 oder
über 18 es bleibt also so wie es jetzt
im moment ist und die bevölkerung soll
verstärkt aufgeklärt werden und soll
verstärkt zur impfung animiert werden
das ist im grunde um der status quo den
wir ohnehin quasi schon haben
fordert die abschaffung der
berufsbezogenen in pflicht das müsste
ein weiteres gesetz geben da müsste man
einschreibung es wäre ein status quo
veränderungen und insofern ist diese
logik hier überhaupt nicht gegeben
jenseits von der tatsache dass hier
diskutiert wurde was gehört denn nun
eigentlich nach oben und da ist es
geübte praxis in deutschland dass der
weitestgehende antrag nach oben gehört
jetzt muss man allerdings ehrenrettung
der impfpflicht freunde absicht sich
sagen hier misst man mit zweierlei maß
es gibt nämlich nur ein gesetzentwurf
und das ist der mit der impfpflicht ab
60 dass die anderen drei dinge sind
anträge und nun könnte man eigentlich
als
ampelkoalition ja argumentieren diese
drei
anträge müssen zunächst abgestimmt
werden und dann nach der reihenfolge wie
es allgemein übliches zunächst die
anträge mit der größten relevanz der
größten veränderungen und dann der
antrag am schluss der die wenigste
veränderung hat das würde bedeuten man
müsste eigentlich dem cdu in vorsorge
gesetzt nach der logik anfangen und wäre
dann bei den dritten antrag eben bei dem
antrag von herrn kubicki und erst dann
am schluss würde man den gesetzentwurf
verabschieden der sich auch durchaus
unterscheidet zu den drei anträgen diese
logik wäre nachvollziehbar das was jetzt
hier abgestimmt wird von den
der abgeordneten vom bundestag scheinbar
vorgegeben sind zwei
reihenfolgen die absolut nicht erklärbar
sind also noch mal um es
zusammenzufassen damit sie es auch
endgültig verstanden haben meine damen
und herren die abgaben stimmen jetzt
über die reihenfolge über die nachher
abgestimmt werden soll die cdu csu
möchte gerne dass mit dem gesetzentwurf
im pflicht ab 60 angefangen wird dann
ihre eigene vorsorge gesetzt dann der
antrag von herrn kubicki und dann der
antrag der afg das schon mal ein
merkwürdiger reihung und die ampel
koalition wollen im grunde um das
umgekehrte merkwürdig mit der afg
anzufangen dann kubicki dann die cdu/csu
und am schluss den eigenen gesetzentwurf
warum ist das so dahinter steckt
natürlich eine gewisse logik die
hoffnung beider lager wenn sozusagen
der eigene antrag oder das eigene gesetz
am schluss kommt dann können einige doch
noch da vielleicht zustimmen bevor
überhaupt nichts in diesem land sich
ändert hofft zumindest ja auch viele in
der ampel dass dann der ein oder andere
cdu-abgeordnete sagt gute stimme ich dem
gesetzentwurf im pflicht ab 60 zion wie
ernst diese ganze sache ist sieht man
daran dass die cdu/csu der
parlamentarische geschäftsführer an alle
abgeordneten gestern einen brief
verschickt hat und dort drin die
abgeordneten aufgefordert hat auch ein
seltener vorgang ist nämlich mal nicht
zu weit aus dem fenster den übrigen
vorlagen nicht zuzustimmen wenn der
eigene antrag nicht abgestimmt wird bloß
nicht am schluss auch noch der
gesetzesvorlage zuzustimmen damit irgend
ein ergebnis vorliegt sondern dann wird
eben hier heute keiner die mehrheit
kriegen und es wird weiter beraten das
ist der rat der der
cdu-fraktionsspitze das ist schon sehr
merkwürdig und ehrlich gesagt jetzt
urteilen sie selbst also dass man eine
bundes außenministerin von einem
nato-treffen zurückruft damit sie hier
auch ihre stimme ab lebt auch dieses ist
eigentlich ein einmaliger vorgang meine
damen und herren daran sehen sie dass es
allen seiten nicht nur um die sache geht
es geht hier ganz klar auch um
machtpolitik um die frage ob der kanzler
dann doch noch eine mehrheit hat in der
ampel koalition hatte sich nicht da hat
die fdp im einen strich durch die
rechnung gemacht aber vielleicht mit
hilfe des einen oder anderen
cdu-abgeordneten hofft man hier die
hürde zu nehmen es geht eigentlich
überhaupt nicht um die kanzlerin hätte
es geht um eine ganz einfache mehrheit
aber die befürworter der impfpflicht ab
60 wenn man mal groben hochrechnet wer
sich da so geoutet hat dann sind das
ungefähr
280 abgeordnete
bei 369 abgeordneten hätte man in jedem
fall eine sichere mehrheit den 280
abgeordnete kann ja bedeuten dass 282
abgeordnete mit nein stimmen und dann
hätte dieser gesetzentwurf keine
mehrheit so das war alles jetzt ein
bisschen viel zum verdauen meine damen
und herren wenn ich ihnen jetzt noch
sage dass die anträge hinterher auch
alle namentlich abgestimmt werden und
dadurch der bundestag immer unterbrochen
wird dann sehen sie schon was für ein
kompliziertes verfahren hier heute
stattfindet aber sie können sich auf
phoenix verlassen auch im 26 jahr
unseres bestehens den phoenix feiert
heute 25 jährigen geburtstag und sie
meine damen und herren sollten sie auch
schon so lange dabei sein wir bedanken
uns bei unseren zuschauern und sie
wissen dass phoenix ihr kompetenter
sender ist für die bundestags-
berichterstattung alle male und deswegen
werden wir ihnen heute hier auch an
durchaus informativen nachmittag
bereiten bleiben sie also bei uns wir
haben auch noch verschiedene gespräche
und verschiedene andere aspekte die wir
für sie aufgearbeitet haben und am
schluss steht dann sicherlich irgendwann
ein ergebnis und im moment kann keiner
sagen ob es hier heute einen
mehrheitsbeschluss gibt oder nicht
und ich darf jetzt erst einmal kurz
abgeben zu meinem kollegen in unser
bonner studio mittlerweile ist unser
studio wieder in bonn fertig und dort
begrüße ich den kollegen bernd rasen
vielen dank joachim von fall war sie
haben es eben gerade schon gesagt die
wir zuschauerinnen und zuschauer sie
versäumen hier nichts wir bleiben
natürlich im bundestag immer mit einem
auge und wenn dort etwas passiert dann
sind wir sofort für sie da momentan
läuft ja jetzt erst mal die abstimmung
zur geschäftsordnung also in welchem er
in welcher reihenfolge werden gleich die
anträge zur impfpflicht behandelt und
abgestimmt und dann werden wir das er
auch schon dieses ergebnis für sie dann
live hier berichten ja und wir schauen
auf die weltpolitik auf die ukraine sei
ist noch ein mitglied im hause dass
seine stimme nicht abgegeben hat
ich sehe jetzt niemanden rennen das
scheint nicht der fall zu sein ich
schließe die abstimmung und bitte die
schriftführerin und schriftführer mit
der auszählung zu beginnen
bis zum vorliegen des ergebnisses
unterbreche ich die sitzung
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
die unterbrochene sitzung ist wieder
eröffnet nehmen sie bitte wieder platz
ich darf ihnen das protokoll der
abstimmung über die abstimmungs
reihenfolge verlesen
mitgliederzahl im deutschen bundestag
736 abgegebene stimmkarten
686 es gab keine ungültige stimmen karte
von den abgegebenen stimmen entfielen
auf reihenfolge 1
345 stimmen und auf reihenfolge 2
339 stimmen
enthaltungen
enthaltungen 2
entsprechend des ausgezählten
ergebnisses der abstimmung werden wir in
folgender reihenfolge
abstimmen reihenfolge 1 das bedeutet
gesetzentwurf behrens janitschek und
andere antrag cdu csu antrag kubicki und
andere antrag afd
bevor wir zu den abstimmungen kommen
bitte ich um ihre aufmerksamkeit für
einige hinweise zum abstimmungsverfahren
der ausschuss für gesundheit hat in
seiner beschlussempfehlung auf
drucksache 13 53 unter buchstaben b c
und d empfohlen über die anträge auf den
drucksachen
978 und 516 im plenum einen beschluss
herbeizuführen
selbst aber keine inhaltliche empfehlung
abgegeben unter buchstabe a seiner
beschlussempfehlung hat der ausschuss
die gesetzentwürfe der gruppen während
und janácek auf drucksachen
899 und
954 zusammengeführt und in einer
ausschuss fassung vorgelegt über die
vorlagen stimmen wir nun in der
festgelegten reihenfolge die ich eben
verlesen habe ab wird eine vorlage
angenommen
entfällt die abstimmung über die
weiteren vorlagen
wir kommen also jetzt zuerst
namentlichen abstimmung
[Applaus]
das schön dass sie sich darüber freuen
also wir stimmen jetzt ab
über den gesetzentwurf behrens
janitschek und andere der gesetz zur
pandemie versorgung vorsorge durch
aufklärung verpflichtende impfberatung
und immunisierung der bevölkerung gegen
saas kopf zwei in der ausschuss fassung
hierbei handelt es sich um die im
ausschuss für gesundheit erfolgte
zusammenführung des gesetzentwurfs der
gruppe heike behrens und anderer mit dem
gesetzentwurf der gruppe die italiener
check und anderer das sind die
drucksachen 899 954 und
1353 es ist namentliche abstimmung
verlangt
ich bitte die schriftführerin
schriftführer die sind glaube ich schon
da und sind auch da geblieben wie ich
höre dass es wunderbar dann eröffne ich
jetzt die namentliche abstimmung über
den gesetzentwurf
und ich gebe ihnen wieder zehn minuten
zeit das haben sie eben auch geschafft
das schaffen wir jetzt wieder
die abstimmung endet um 12 uhr 30
vielen dank bernd raser meine damen und
herren die erste abstimmung ist hier
schon erfolgt da ging es um die
reihenfolge in der die verschiedenen
vorschläge abgestimmt werden sollen die
union wollte ja mit dem gesetzentwurf an
dann den eigenen entwurf im vorsorge
gesetzt danach den entwurf von herrn
kubicki der sich gegen die impfung
wendet aber sagt es muss weiter für
impfungen gebohrt worden werden aber
keine zwangsimpfung und dann der antrag
der afg der gegen jegliche impfpflicht
ist und die abschaffung der
berufsbezogenen impfpflicht will
und soeben war dann das ergebnis da wir
wollten jetzt den außenpolitischen
glücklich unterbrechen aber es hat
tatsächlich eine riesen überraschung
gegeben von 736 abgeordnete haben
686 abgestimmt und in der tat ist der
wunsch der opposition es war ja nicht
nur die cdu sondern auch die linken und
die fdp die das in der form gefordert
haben ist dem wunsch nachgekommen worden
345 abgeordnete für diese reihenfolge 3
139 abgeordnete nur für die reihenfolge
der ampel sag ich mal verkürzt warum kam
das so ich glaube das hauptargument was
hier bei einigen abgeordneten auch aus
den ampel fraktionen gezogen hat ist die
tatsache dass der weitestgehende antrag
in dem fall sogar der gesetzentwurf
immer und überall in dieser republik als
erstes abgestimmt wird und ich hätte es
formal auch nicht anders ausdrücken
können es gibt eigentlich nur diesen
einen gesetzentwurf auf den es dann
wirklich ankommt ob wirklich einer der
anträge hinterher noch eine mehrheit
kriegt das ist ja die große frage jetzt
geht es also in den sekunden wo wir hier
die abstimmung sehen sind die
abgeordneten aufgerufen noch weitere
sechs minuten abzustimmen will man
diesen impfpflicht an die impfpflicht ab
60 unterstützen mit beratungspflicht und
dann eventuell im herbst entscheiden
dass auch alle ab 18 geimpft werden
müssen also will man die impfpflicht auf
diese art und weise wie es zum beispiel
der gesundheitsminister fordert wie ist
der bundeskanzler fordert und dieser
kompromissantrag ich ja aus der
allgemeinen impfpflicht einer gruppe
heraus gegangen und aus der impfpflicht
ab 50 jahren vorher verpflichtende
beratung der gruppe ullmann die haben
fusioniert die beiden gruppen kommen
rechnerisch auf so 280 290 abgeordneten
stimmen und sie sehen das von 686 da
sind und abstimmen dann braucht man für
die einfache mehrheit noch ein paar
abgeordnete aus den anderen lagern und
darum ging es auch bei der reihenfolge
festlegung das ist natürlich ungünstig
jetzt für diesen gesetzentwurf denn
natürlich kann man als cdu abgeordneter
sagen ich habe diesen gesetzentwurf
finde ich nicht so gut wie unseren
eigenen den wir vorlegen unseren antrag
zum in vorsorge gesetzt er wird ja erst
danach abgestimmt und deswegen warte ich
doch noch mal mit meinem jahr also das
ist schon eine kleine vorentscheidung
liebt mich da mal fest und ich weiß
nicht annalena baerbock kann so schnell
fliegen wie sie will aber wahrscheinlich
wird es auf ihre stimme am schluss nicht
mehr ankommen und wir melden uns hier in
wenigen minuten wieder denn die
verkündung dieses ergebnisses wollen wir
ihnen dann auch live mitteilen jetzt ist
es fünf minuten vor halb deshalb haben
die abgeordneten hier noch zeit um
abzustimmen danach wird ausgezählt und
wir melden uns wieder einstweilen geht
es weiter mit meinem kollegen bernd
rasen
dankeschön der joachim von fall war wir
sind zurück sobald sich in berlin wieder
etwas tut wir bleiben beim thema ukraine
ist noch ein mitglied im hause dass
seine stimme noch nicht abgegeben hat
dann bitte jetzt sehr zügig abgeben und
in diesem zuge möchte ich noch einmal
darauf hinweisen dass zahlreiche
persönliche erklärungen zu diesen
abstimmungen hier abgegeben wurden ja
jetzt bitte ganz schnell 12 uhr 30
wollten wir schließen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wer seine
stimme noch nicht abgegeben hat möge das
jetzt bitte sofort tun
so wie ich es sehe haben jetzt alle ihre
stimme ab ich sie jetzt tatsächlich noch
jemanden laufen
also liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
jetzt beeilen sie sich doch bitte
vielleicht sage ich das hier noch einmal
es wäre ganz passend wenn sie jetzt in
den nächsten abstimmungen nicht
zwischendurch essen gehen oder irgendwo
anders hin das sind wirklich kurze
zeiträume damit wir auch durchkommen
das für sie
der phönix warum haben das live signal
ich richtig spannend die frage wird es
in deutschland eine impfpflicht geben
oder nicht dies jetzt schon entschieden
warum sie ist das so weil soeben die un-
geschlossen wurden die abstimmung über
den gesetzentwurf bei dem ja vor allen
dingen oder nur ampel
mitglieder sich versammelt haben nämlich
der kompromissentwurf impfpflicht ab 60
vorher beratung verpflichtend für alle
ab 18 und im herbst eventuell dann nach
dem sachstand dann auch eine impfpflicht
ab 18 darüber haben die abgeordneten
jetzt hier abgestimmt es bleiben jetzt
ungefähr zehn minuten wo ausgezählt wird
die ampel fraktionen wollten gerne ein
anderes verfahren sie wollten dass
dieser gesetzentwurf das ist der einzige
von den vieren die hier vorliegende ist
andere da sind nämlich anträge dass
dieser gesetzentwurf am schluss
abgestimmt wird da hat die opposition
und die sono argumentiert dass es extrem
ungewöhnlich weil der weitestgehende
antrag beschluss gesetzentwurf wird in
allen ortsverbänden deutschland wird in
der politik grundsätzlich am anfang
abgestimmt warum ist das so ist ja ganz
logisch wenn der dann angenommen würde
ja dann entfallen die anderen dann spart
man auch eine menge zeit aber es war
schon eine überraschung muss ich sagen
dass diese reihenfolge die die ampel
fraktionen hier vorgelegt haben nicht
die mehrheit gefunden hat sondern die
reihenfolge die die opposition vorgelegt
hat nämlich das erst über den
gesetzentwurf und dann über die anträge
abgestimmt wird das ergebnis war
allerdings wirklich knapp 300 je selber
gucken 45 zu 339 also eine knappe
angelegenheit und knapp kann es ja jetzt
hier auch bei dem gesetzentwurf werden
denn für eine allgemeine impfpflicht
modifizierten pflicht ab 60 für den
ursprungs antrag hatten sich ungefähr
237 abgeordnete gefunden unter anderem
der bundeskanzler und auch der
bundesgesundheitsminister und dann hat
die gruppe um herrn will man den
gesundheitspolitiker der fdp die
eigentlich eine langjährige beratung
wollten und im herbst entscheiden
wollten ob sie dann doch die über 50
jährigen dann impfen müssen die haben
gesagt also hier gar kein ergebnis
zustande kommen haben sich gestern
zusammengeschlossen diese gruppe hatte
45 personen der ein oder andere wird da
vielleicht nicht mitmachen also kommen
wir bei 280 290 abgeordneten an und sie
haben es vielleicht mitbekommen der
bundeskanzler soll sogar die
außenministerin aus brüssel zurück
gerufen haben damit sie hier ab stimmt
ich weiß nicht ob sich noch rechtzeitig
genug angekommen ist jedenfalls sind die
ohren jetzt zu und wir warten jetzt auf
das ergebnis und das tue ich gemeinsam
mit beatrix von storch von der afg sie
haben ja auch einen antrag vorliegen
reden wir gleich darüber vor von storch
aber ganz ehrlich das war jetzt schon
eine überraschung dass im grunde
genommen obwohl es hier
fraktionsübergreifende gruppenanträge
geht aber bei der geschäftsordnung der
ging es letzten endes natürliche
koalition gegen opposition und die
opposition der oppositions wille hat
gewonnen da haben einige aus der
koalitions ampeln doch mit bestimmt
warum ja das ist ein ganz großes theater
was hier heute gespielt wird aber es ist
ein sehr wichtiges und es geht um etwas
dass dieses theater nicht abgebildet es
ist etwas unwürdig wie ich finde wie
hier vorgegangen wird wir wollen oder
wir sollten darüber entscheiden dass es
eine impfpflicht geben wird und alleine
das prozess ist so chaotisch gewesen
dass man eigentlich heute darüber gar
nicht abstimmen kann gestern im